olivier ferrand ministre des solidarités
et de la santé vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente monsieur rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les députés
nous voilà donc à nouveau réunis pour
l'examen d'un projet de loi relatif à la
crise sanitaire depuis 15 mois
le parlement est sollicitée intervalles
réguliers pour trouver le juste
équilibre entre le maintien de nos
libertés et la nécessaire protection des
plus vulnérables face à un virus qui a
déjà tué plus de cent mille de nos
concitoyens en 15 mois la vie des
français à changer leur quotidien a été
bouleversée et je comprends la lassitude
la fatigue et parfois la colère beaucoup
de sacrifices ont été consentis ces
sacrifices ils sont la traduction en
actes de nos valeurs n'ont pas de valeur
abstraite désincarné mais des valeurs de
solidarité qui n'ont de sens que si elle
est engagée mobilise chacune et chacun
d'entre nous je souhaite vous remercier
et par votre intermédiaire remercier
tous les français de leur patience de
leur courage et leur abnégation au cours
de ces derniers mois
je souhaite aussi vous remercier
parlementaire pour votre vigilance au
quotidien et pour votre souci constant
de trouver un juste équilibre entre de
liberté et la protection des français
ce juste équilibre ne saurait être une
décision unanime capable de satisfaire
chacun ce juste équilibre ça n'est pas
non plus un consensus mou un pis-aller
ce juste équilibre c'est celui de
l'intérêt général
et nous ne sommes pas ici pour servir
autre chose l'état d'urgence sanitaire
n'a pas été une fantaisie pas plus qu'il
n'a été comme je lé souvent entendu un
excès de prudence
non l'état d'urgence a permis de donner
un cadre juridique et démocratique à des
décisions sans précédent qui se sont
toujours appuyés sur des données
scientifiques sur notre connaissance du
virus sur le moyen de lutter contre
celui-ci
notre seul et unique objectif a été de
protéger la santé des français c'est un
choix que nous avons pris avec gravité
avec responsabilité
et ce n'est pas avec gaieté de coeur que
l'on prend des décisions comme celles
qui ont été prises aujourd'hui c'est
avec un optimisme et une confiance
raisonnable que je soumets à votre
examen ce projet de loi de sortie de
crise sanitaire
si les indicateurs ne sont pas au vert
loin s'en faut
il donne à voir une amélioration
sensible de la situation épidémique
la vaccination s'est accélérée 18
millions de nos concitoyens ont reçu au
moins une dose de vaccin
le nombre de patients en réanimation a
commencé à décroître il avait dépassé
les 6000 nous sommes actuellement à un
peu moins de 5000 patients qu'aux vide
en réanimation et la courbe de la baisse
des animations laisse présager que si
cette baisse se poursuit à ce rythme
nous atteindront ensuite la barre des
4000 puis peut-être la barre des 3min
ben etc alors nous pourrons reprendre
des soins programmés dans les meilleures
conditions
dans nos hôpitaux le taux de positivité
est également en baisse il est passé de
6,2 à 5,8 pour cent et enfin nous
enregistrons une diminution du taux
d'incidence depuis trois semaines
consécutives dans toutes les classes
d'âge nous diagnostiquons quelques 18
mille malades par jour c'est encore
beaucoup c'est encore trop mais c'est
deux fois moins que les 40 mille malades
par jour qui était diagnostiquée lorsque
nous avons dû mettre en place des
mesures de freinage et le taux
d'incidence lui aussi avoisine désormais
les deux sens ce sont des signaux qui
ont très encourageant qui montre que les
mesures ont été efficaces
une fois encore et qui nous amène à
envisager de manière plus sereine la
suite de cette lutte contre l'épidémie
ce sont des signaux qui rendent possible
une adaptation des mesures de protection
sanitaire et qui nous permet de nous
projeter de manière progressive en
dehors du régime de l'état d'urgence
cette amélioration de la situation ne
peut nous exonérer d'une vigilance qui
est absolument nécessaire pour éviter la
propagation du virus et appelé au
maintien la vigilance n'est en rien une
posture si l'on tient compte du fait que
la mortalité liée aux qu'ovide rester
élevée que la tension hospitalière bien
qu'en baisse restent fortes dans
beaucoup de territoire métropolitain et
ultramarin
enfin au chapitre des indicateurs je
rappelle que nous avons encore en
réanimation plus de patients malades du
cobp id qu'au pic de la deuxième vague
le projet de loi de sortie de la crise
sanitaire ne donc ne marque donc pas une
rupture nette
entre les contraintes qu'impose
l'épidémie et le retour à la vie d'avant
il fixe un cap un cap vers l'objectif
d'un retour tant espéré à notre vie
d'avant il dessine des perspectives une
install de manière progressive et
pérenne les conditions d'un retour à la
normale mais dans des conditions sûres
efficaces et durables
ce retour à la normale nous n'avons
cessé de le chercher au sein de cette
assemblée par le débat par une
discussion qui n'a jamais été
interrompues depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
rien que l'intitulé de ce texte est à d
état d'urgence sanitaire
8 en atteste la question de la
résolution de cette crise a été
l'occasion d'échangés parfois vifs au
sein de cette assemblée il était
nécessaire pour parvenir à des décisions
équilibrées et pour construire ensemble
des mesures de protection des
populations et à chaque fois à chaque
fois c'est au final l'esprit de
responsabilité qui l'attend porter ce
projet de loi ne déroge pas cet esprit
de responsabilité et en tenant compte
d'une réalité épidémique encore sensible
il s'efforce de créer un régime de
sortie de crise sanitaire à la fois
sérieux et raisonnable ce texte consacre
des évolutions majeures d'abord c'est la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
déclaré le 14 octobre dernier et
prolongé depuis lors ensuite c'est la
fin des mesures de confinement et ce dès
le 2 juin
cependant il reste nécessaire de
conserver à titre temporaire
l'outil qu'est le couvre feu cette
demande est pragmatique elle permet de
ne pas solliciter une nouvelle
reconduction d'un état d'urgence
sanitaire avec les larges possibilités
de couvre-feu qui l'emporterait un
amendement du gouvernement en commission
permet ainsi de maintenir un couvre-feu
spécifique temporaire très encadrée du 2
au 30 juin 2021 inclut donc pour un mois
uniquement
il autorise un couvre-feu plus tardive
que l'horaire actuel puisqu'il ne pourra
et ne pourrait être plus précoce que 21h
cette mesure se veut une dernière étape
une dernière étape progressive d'un
régime de sortie n est pas destiné à
rester figé dans le marbre comme s'y est
engagé le président de la république en
annonçant que cette heure serait
susceptible d'être repoussé encore
davantage si la situation sanitaire
venait à s'améliorer
à certaines échéances déjà annoncées
troisièmement et par ailleurs nous
savons que la circulation du virus n'est
pas la même d'un territoire à l'autre ce
qui a d'ailleurs justifié des mesures
territorialisée à de nombreuses reprises
le gouvernement souhaite que ce
dispositif soit maintenu pour répondre à
une éventuelle dégradation
localisé de la situation sanitaire
pendant la période estivale sans
maintenir un couvre-feu plus strictes
pour l'ensemble de la population c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons que ce
dispositif de renforcement des mesures
sanitaires territorialisée adopté en
commission mme la présidente soit
maintenue par ailleurs et beaucoup de
députés y tenait ce texte permet de
verser les données pseudonyme is et des
systèmes d'information qu'ovide au sein
du système national des données de santé
afin de pouvoir les conserver après la
fin de la crise sanitaire et uniquement
uniquement à des fins de recherche
aucune latitude n'a été prise avec le
respect de la confidentialité des
données
mesdames messieurs les députés la
campagne vaccinale progresse avec l nos
espoirs grandissent qu'est ce que le
vaccin va nous offrir comme liberté
quelle protection nous apportera-t-il
ces questions sont parfaitement
légitimes mais elle crée également
beaucoup de confusion comme c'est le cas
du pass sanitaire premiers éléments se
passe sanitaire n'est pas un passe
vaccinale pour le valider un test pcr ou
antigénique pourront être des éléments
de preuve suffisants se passe à lithaire
est avant tout un outil de sécurisation
du repli épidémique et d'accélération
c'est un point essentiel de la
réouverture progressive des commerces
des restaurants et des grands événements
il prend deux formes au sein de ce
projet doit d'abord impasse frontières
et ensuite un pass grands événements le
premier permet de soumettre les
déplacements longue distance à une
attestation de vaccination ou de
rétablissement
alternativement aux résultats négatifs
d'un tests virologiques le second a été
introduit par voie d'amendement en
commission se passe sanitaire subordonne
l'accès des personnes à certains lieux
établissements ou événements impliquant
de grands rassemblements
le conseil scientifique consultés sur
cette orientation a vendu le lundi 3 mai
un avis dans lequel il estime que le
pass sanitaire utilisé de manière
temporaire peut permettre à la
population une forme de retour à la vie
normale en
minimisant les risques de contamination
ce dispositif ne sera pas je le dis
étendue aux activités du quotidien et
bien évidemment les mesures sanitaires
barrières restent maintenus même avec ce
pass sanitaires nous veillerons à ce que
l'interdiction qui a été établie en
commission au sujet des activités du
quotidien soient bien respectées et
sanctionner le cas échéant dans les
mêmes conditions que les contraventions
relatives aux établissements recevant du
public et au lieu de réunion que nous
connaissons dans le régime actuel
le pass reste le meilleur moyen de
valoriser l'ensemble des efforts de
vaccination que nous avons mises en
place pour permettre plus d'activités
plus d'événements sportifs culturels
là où nous prenions sinon le risque de
fermeture ou de restriction encore plus
prolongée prévu explicitement pour le
régime de sortie ses facultés seront
également mobilisable en état d'urgence
sanitaire s'il devait être déclarée de
nouveau ce que nul ne souhaite
évidemment afin de parer à toute
éventualité il sera proposé sur ce même
point de rétablir l'aménagement limitée
des règles de prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
mais uniquement s'il devait ne concerner
que des territoires très limité et moins
de 10% de nos compatriotes cet été ce
afin d'avoir d'éviter d'avoir à
organiser un nouveau rendez vous
législatifs à une date à laquelle vos
travaux seront suspendus et qui peuvent
nécessiter de prendre des décisions
d'urgence et chacun peut se souvenir
l'été dernier alors que l'épidémie était
sinon au point mort en tout cas très
basses la réémergence de karma yen qui
nécessitait intervenir très vite et qui
nous a évité une deuxième vague au coeur
de l'été et les territoires ultramarins
que je vous demande de ne pas oublier
dans le raisonnement car l'hémisphère
sud l'été dernier a été marqué par des
vagues épidémiques très fortes qui ont
impacté notamment le territoire guyanais
et qui a nécessité de prendre en urgence
des mesures des pros de la de protection
des populations pour finir le projet de
loi que nous examinons tient compte
évidemment la situation économique du
pays depuis plus d'un an
l'état a prouvé qu'il était capable
d'accompagner quotidiennement et dans la
durée nos entreprises et les salariés
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'adapter
plusieurs mesures d'accompagnement
économique et social prises lors des
étapes précédentes de l'épidémie soit
afin de favoriser la reprise d'activité
comme l'activité
ciel chacune de ces mesures traduit
l'engagement et la persistance du
gouvernement dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus je sais ce que le régime de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire emporte dans
la vie quotidienne des français et de
cette assemblée
je sais aussi que sans vous sans la
force de notre démocratie notre combat
perd son sens et notre avenir est plus
qu'incertain dans le projet que nous
construisons de sortir une bonne fois
pour toute de la crise sanitaire
une bonne fois pour toutes nous devons
poser des jalons trouver ensemble les
conditions par lesquelles la vie pourra
redevenir ce qu'elle était auparavant
c'est ce que propose ce texte c'est ce
que je vous propose
et je sais vous soyez au rendez vous
merci merci messieurs ministère la
parole est à monsieur jean-pierre bon
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
république
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
chers collègues il nous est aujourd'hui
permis d'entrevoir avec toute la
prudence que cette affirmation impose la
sortie d'une période qui est approuvé
notre pays depuis plus d'un an
en ce printemps 2021 si le virus de
lakovic 19 persiste mute et continue de
tuer malgré tous les efforts déployés au
premier rang desquels sur ceux de nos
personnels soignants la campagne de
vaccination est désormais bien engagée
et suscite légitimement l'espoir et la
patience nous devons néanmoins rester
prudents les effets tant attendue du
vaccin sont pour bientôt
et dans cette attente l'effort collectif
consentis par les français doit être
maintenue selon des modalités adaptées
au contexte sanitaire actuelle c'est un
équilibre fragile exigeant que
recherchent donc le présent projet de
loi
favoriser au maximum la reprise des
activités tout en maintenant des mesures
nécessaires à la lutte contre l'épidémie
je me félicite ils s'inscrivent dans la
continuité de la position exprimée par
la commission des lois lors de la
discussion du dernier projet de loi de
provocation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
discutez en début d'année sortir de cet
état d'exception dès que possible et
déterminé au moment opportun le régime
transitoire qui lui succèdera afin de
poursuivre de manière proportionnée la
lutte contre le virus tout en permettant
la reprise des activités et la relance
de la croissance
tel est l'objet de l'article 1er qui
instaure un régime transitoire similaire
à celui bâti à la sortie du premier état
d'urgence sanitaire qui avait été
applicable du 11 juillet au 16 octobre
2020 les débats en commission ont été
fructueux sur cette tactique à la fois
sur la disposition relative aux
passeports sanitaires pour certains
déplacements et sur les deux amendements
du gouvernement suffisant le premier à
mettre en oeuvre un passani terre pour
les activités de loisirs impliquant de
grands rassemblements et le second
permettant de maintenir le couvre feu
jusqu'au 30 juin prochain
il faut se féliciter des garanties et
des précisions dors et déjà apporté en
commission à ces dispositifs
un sous-amendement de notre présidente a
notamment permis d'acter qu aucun
professionnel ne pourrait exiger le
passe en dehors des cas prévus par la
loi comme évoqué plus haut il s'agit
d'éviter toute dérive et de s'assurer
qu'à tel dispositif ne serait exigée
dans le cadre des activités de la vie
quotidienne
je vous précise que nous aurons
l'occasion lors de cette séance de
poursuivre ce travail notamment sur le
dispositif permettant de maintenir
provisoirement le couvre-feu dans le
cadre du régime transitoire
cette disposition constitue une entorse
certes justifiée aux principes selon
lesquels seul l'état d'urgence sanitaire
permet de prendre des mesures
d'interdiction de sortie du domicile
nous apporterons les garanties
supplémentaires nécessaires à sa pleine
acceptation
enfin on situ concerne le terme du
régime transitoire
les débats ont été riches mais je
maintiens que la date proposée le 31
octobre est judicieuse
non seulement d'un point de vue
sanitaire mais aussi social et
économique avancé cette date limite
serait l'application de mesures
d'accompagnement indispensables pour
notre pays j'en viens à l'article 2 qui
prévoyait dans son titre 2 une durée
dérogatoire de déclarations
territoriales
l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour la
période estivale
cette mesure a pu susciter des
interrogations et des critiques
légitimes confirmée par l'avis du
conseil d'état ce qui conduit à la
suppression de cette disposition
le gouvernement présentera un nouveau
dispositif prenant en compte les
proportions les propositions que j'ai
émises et qui permettra de répondre aux
craintes exprimées alors que l'article 3
prévoit l'adaptation des deux premiers
articles en nouvelle calédonie et en
polynésie française
l'article 4 permettra un double
renforcement utile du régime de la
quarantaine et de l' isolement dans la
foulée des récentes décisions prises par
le gouvernement pour l'élargissement
utile de notre contrôle sanitaire aux
frontières et du résume le contrôle des
infractions aux règles de police
sanitaire pour finir sur le régime de
gestion vaquer sanitaires l'article 5 me
semble essentiel car il permet
d'intégrer certaines des données
recueillies par les systèmes
d'information mise en oeuvre afin de
lutter contre l'épidémie de kovy 19 au
système national des données de santé se
faire ce versement se fera de manière
sécurisée et respectueuse de la
protection des données personnelles
il vise à aligner les modalités de
recueil des informations sanitaires
relatives à l'accord et 19 sur le régime
de droit commun et rien que le droit
commun il constitue un outil
indispensable pour améliorer terme
prises en charge et connaissances
médicales pour apprendre à mieux faire
face à d'éventuels prochaine épidémie
j'espère vivement que nos discussions
permettront du dissiper les malentendus
qui ont pu apparaître en commission des
lois sur cet article
je précise daury des gens que les
données concernées ne seront pas des
données identifiantes et personnels
détruites au bout de trois mois mais
bien des données sanitaires sous
pseudonyme
j'ai évoqué les mesures d'accompagnement
prises depuis le début de la crise
l'article 6 prévoit d'en proroger un
certain nombre jusqu'à la fin de la
période transitoire au 31 octobre
de façon tout à fait opportune sont
concernés le fonctionnement des
juridictions ou encore celui des
assemblées délibérantes donc
je salue d'ailleurs sur ce point la
proposition du gouvernement aménageant
le quorum pour les élections des
exécutifs locaux en juin prochain mais
aussi l'organisation des ehpad ou encore
les missions des services de santé au
travail
plus que jamais indispensable
d'autres mesures d'accompagnement
nécessaires pour montre est prolongée et
adapté par voie d'ordonnancé avec
l'article 7 qui porte sur l'activité
partielle la trêve hivernale et la
démonisation chômage des intermittents
je conviens que la méthode des
ordonnances et contestées elle est ici
opportune elle permettra d'adapter des
outils précieux en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
que nous ne pouvons pas encore
appréhender l'article 8 prévoient des
aménagements pour les scrutins de joie
en adaptant la campagne électorale et
des opérations de vote
profession de foi numérique vote en
extérieure affichage électoral est tendu
tout est conçu pour que les scrutins se
déroulent dans les meilleures conditions
pour les candidats et les électeurs
la commission a également clarifié les
mesures prévues en matière de débats
électoraux pour maximiser l'efficacité
en outre à mon initiative et à celle de
notre collègue gouffier chat et le
groupe la république en marche la
commission avec un nouvel article 9
avancer la date limite de délivrance du
récépissé définitif de candidatures
permettant ainsi d'étendre la période
d'affichage électoral
c'est une mesure opportune pour le
principe est d'ailleurs soutenue par le
gouvernement comme en témoigne le décret
paru samedi au journal officiel
enfin la commission a introduit trois
autres nouveaux articles sur proposition
du gouvernement
l'article 6 bis qui prolonge la
dérogation au jour des carences des
agents publics et de certains salariés
jusqu'à la fin du régime transitoire
article 10 prévoit le remboursement des
dépenses de propagande électorale pour
les législatives partielles reporté en
fin d'article le 11 consacre
l'annulation juridique des opérations de
recensement prévu cette année et qui
n'ont pu se tenir du fait de la crise
sanitaire
l'espoir demeure qu'il s'agisse du
dernier nouvel effort demandé aux
français pour se donner toutes les
chances de tourner enfin la page de
cette crise sanitaire
il nous faut réussir à compter du 2 juin
prochain la sortie du second état
d'urgence sanitaire et du troisième
déconfinement selon les modalités
annoncées par le président de la
république le 29 avril 2021 est
organisée par le présent projet de loi
je vous remercie merci messieurs à
porter
j'ai reçu de madame valérie un beau et
des membres du groupe socialiste et
apparentés une motion de rejet préalable
déposé en application d'un petit 91
alinéa 5 du règlement
la parole est à marietta karamanli jeux
dispo merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre la présidente la
commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
la france devrait sortir de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire le 2 juin mais le
gouvernement entend conserver les
prérogatives importantes jusqu'en
octobre
c'est l'objet de ce nouveau texte du 2
juin au 31 octobre inclus
c'est à dire pendant cinq mois le
premier ministre aura la compétence de
prendre des mesures
je cite par décret dans l'intérêt de la
santé publique et aux seules fins de
lutter contre la propagation de
l'épidémie de gavin 19
il va pouvoir réglementer ou interdire
dans certaines parties du territoires
dans lesquels est constaté une
circulation active du virus
la circulation des personnes et des
véhicules se réserve déplacements
strictement indispensables aux besoins
familiaux professionnels et de santé et
pour réglementer l'accès de locaux
ouverts au public
il pourra aussi réglementer les
rassemblements de personnes
les réunions et les activités sur la
voie publique et dans les lieux ouverts
au public pour répondre à des
dégradations localisait de la situation
sanitaire le texte précise que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire pourrait toutefois
être déclarée ce qu'au 31 octobre dans
une ou plusieurs circonscriptions
territoriales déterminée pour aider les
porteurs de moi
pour résumer donc la philosophie de ce
texte il organise une sortie en l'état
avec réaffirmation d'une délégation
permanente au profit de l'exécutif à
limiter les libertés publiques et
individuelles et la possibilité aussi de
déléguer ce pouvoir aux préfets dans le
cadre d'une gestion territorialisées
certes le projet de loi prévoit
l'information du parlement sur une
partie des mesures prises
le parlement a accepté en mars on met en
juillet en novembre 2020 puis en février
2021 dernier d'accorder au gouvernement
des pouvoirs exceptionnels face à la
crise tout au long de ces presque quinze
mois nous avons pu espérer que des
mesures d'encadrement général de pouvoir
ainsi donné serait examinée aujourd'hui
encore sur un mode dégradé ce texte
confie au premier ministre
toutes les mesures que l'état d'urgence
induit ce qui était déjà la critique
faite au moment de la précédente loi de
sortie nous étions en juin 2020 en
l'état certaines restrictions aux
libertés fondamentales pourrait être
maintenu plusieurs mois sans aucune
intervention de notre assemblée
je le rappelle un accord pour mettre en
oeuvre des limitations aux libertés
publiques et individuelles suppose que
celle ci soit temporaire que le
parlement soit appelait à voter
régulièrement et aussi que les juges
s'assurent de la proportionnalité de
telles mesures
les propositions d'amendements que notre
groupe a défendu et défendra se
nourrissent de ces principes sous la
motion de rejet que ce texte pour nous
se justifie selon nous pour plusieurs
raisons d'ailleurs 4-6 6-4 raisons
d'abord le cadre transitoire ni par un
cadre de décélération des mesures de
police mais en y tant les possibilités
et la longévité potentiel
les imprécisions juridique que relaie
corcelles ce projet les modifications
significatives proposé par le
gouvernement par voie d'amendement
concernant l'instauration d'un pass
sanitaires et la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence par la loi pour deux mois pour
certaines parties du territoire
représentant un pourcentage de la
population
tout d'abord un régime transitoire qui
part ça durait supplante toutes les
proposer une prorogation autorisé de
façon expresse le cadre proposé maintien
alors même qu'on évoque une sortie de
mesures relatives aux déplacements et
moyens de transport aux établissements
recevant du public et ressemblement de
la voile sur la voie publique dans les
mêmes conditions que l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
il s'agit de ces fameux freins qui
peuvent être actionnés selon une logique
de sortie politique affichée mais pas
scientifiquement argumenté le texte
offre la possibilité de maintenir le
couvre-feu entre 21h et 6h du matin il
habite je l' ai dit plus haut les
préfets à prendre des mesures
d'application ou des mesures générales
dans ce cadre est en quelque sorte
délègue à l'administration déconcentrée
des mesures réservé à l'exécutif sont il
est vrai que la représentation nationale
année le suivi et assure le contrôle ces
mesures pourront concrètement faire du
ray l'état d'urgence délégué est un
rideau réalisé pour une durée totale de
cinq mois soit une durée supérieure à
toutes les précédentes prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire autorisée par
la loi et ce sans intervention du
parlement
parallèlement le contrôle parlementaire
demeurera limitée dans les mêmes
conditions que nous avons dénoncées
précédemment et nous n'auront toujours
pas une visibilité précise sur les
mesures générales prises
individuellement par les préfets mais
sur qui ont été pour beaucoup
à l'origine d'ailleurs de contentieux
venons en maintenant à la question d'un
cadre légal peu précis et par là même
qui interroge alors que toutes les
restrictions aux libertés doivent être
limités donc précise et promotionnels à
l'objectif poursuivi
concernant la délégation sont précision
ni contrôle donc effectif
la question de la compréhension de
l'incompétence négative
l'article le premier prévoit que
l'habilitation donnée au gouvernement
pour réglementer la circulation des
personnes ou l'ouverture de certains
établissements lui permet d'aller
jusqu'à une interdiction
or confinement strict au domicile dès
lors qu'il y à une circulation active du
virus ni le projet de loi ni son exposé
des motifs ni l'étude d'impact ne
précise la définition de cette
circulation active alors même qu'elles
conditionnent un important renforcement
du pouvoir réglementaire du premier
ministre nous avons proposé en
commission de le définir à partir du
taux d'incidence constatait sur une
semaine glissante soit à 400 cas
positifs pour 100000 habitants seuil
dallaire d'ailleurs évoqué par le
président de la république pour le
déconfinement soit à 254 positif pour
100000 habitants seuil recommandé par la
communauté scientifique cette fois-ci et
médical et anciennement seuil d alerte
pour l'administration
en l'absence d'une telle précision avec
ce seuil ou un autre le gouvernement
donc pourrait de fait basculer aisément
dans un régime d'interdiction
il s'agit d'un cas on d'un état d'
incompétence négative nous semble-t-il
où le législateur n'aurait pas épuisé
sa compétence est à dire où la loi
serait alors trop imprécises ou ambiguës
rang verte et roberto au pouvoir
réglementaire des grèves en tout cas aux
autorités d'application de la loi
manifesterait une intervention
insuffisante du législateur et ou encore
autoriserait si vous me permettez
l'expression une privation de garantie
légale
autrement dit ce serait donc une
omission du parlement cet état dans
compétences négative qui s ajoutent aux
obligations de clarté d'intelligibilité
de la loire est particulièrement évident
s'agissant du mécanisme introduit par
voie d'amendement et constituant le pass
sanitaires celui-ci serait applicable à
certains lieux établissements ou
événements
qu'un cadre de soi précisait quant au
type et classes d'établissements
recevant du public ou à la nature
ouverte ou fermée des lieux concernés la
rédaction de l'article évoque d'ailleurs
du grand rassemblement de personnes mais
ne donne pas de précision quant aux
jojo's applicable au nombre de personnes
ont une densité
enfin la disposition un hummer les
activités concernées comme les activités
de loisirs notamment sans distinguer ce
qui relève des activités sportives
culturelles ou simplement de balades
dans un espace dans un grand espace vert
raconte m
elle ne distingue au sein de celle ci
l'entrée dans un cinéma de quartier de
80 places d'un concert à bercy et c'est
18000 places d'une manifestation de
quartier à l'extérieur de 50 personnes
ou d'un événement à plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de spectateurs
au delà donc des questions d'
incompétence négative de clarté de la
loi qui déjà en tâches probablement
cette disposition de non conformité à la
constitution se pose la question de la
protection des données personnelles qui
n'est pas traitée par le texte
nous reviendrons sur le passé ni terre
dans quelques instants mais il ne soit
possible qu'il ne soit possible ici et
dans blade de dire qu'il utilisera des
données personnelles relatives à l'état
de santé et qu'à ce titre il constitue
un précédent dont il convient de limiter
les effets en termes de duret et
d'ampleur par nature les personnes qui
seront amenés à contrôler le pass and i
ter seront majoritairement des personnes
morales ou physiques autre que les
administrations aucune garantie n'est
prévue quant à la conservation et à
l'utilisation de ses données
personnelles de santé tels qu'un
agrément des personnes amenées à
procéder à ces contrôles enfin
l'introduction du passé ni terre par un
amendement du gouvernement dans
l'article 39 de la constitution et
l'article 8 de la loi organique du 15
avril 2009 prévoit l'obligation pour le
gouvernement de soumettre les projets de
loi à l'avis du conseil d'état et à
l'écho accompagné d'une étude d'impact
ces documents
transmis au parlement constituent des
éléments essentiels à la bonne
information des parlementaires en amont
des débats qui peuvent alors décider de
toute connaissance de cause le projet de
loi relatif à la gestion de la sortie de
la crise sanitaire a été déposée le 28
avril 2021 sur le bureau de l'assemblée
nationale est le gouvernement a déposé
son amendement sur le pass unitaire le 3
mai soit seulement cinq jours plus tard
sur ce sujet à discussion au début
plusieurs semaines tant au niveau
français qu'européen
le gouvernement ne serait laissé penser
qu'il a été contraint par l'urgence à
intégrer cette disposition
après le dépôt du projet de loi surtout
au regard de la pauvreté de sa rédaction
le gouvernement a manifestement fait le
choix de contourner l'obligation d'avis
du conseil d'état et d'étude d'impact
pour s'épargner impossible jugement peu
favorable du conseil
si le conseil constitionnel a encore
jamais retenu de situations similaires
pour prononcer une censure il s'agit de
faire de fait d'une disposition à mener
ses longues procédures au moins dans
l'esprit contraire à la constitution
tu sois donc possible que bien de dire
que nous trouvons étrange que nous ne
sachions pas à ce stade ci se passe se
rallier au téléchargement de
l'application est subordonnée à son
utilisation
si la démarche est donc de plus celle
lancée par l'union européenne et si oui
et comment s'articulent avec elle
quelles garanties suffisantes
l'entourent en tout cas cela fait partie
de nos réserves
il ne devrait pas y avoir transmission
des données personnelles et des
garanties doivent être donnés surfe sur
qui pourra consulter les données et
qu'elle donnait enfin se passe ne doit
pas créer de discrimination ou
d'inégalités je le dis alors même que la
vaccination de toute la population ne
sera pas faite au moment de sa mise en
oeuvre la démarche suivie pour le
proposait ce qui a exclu et l'avis du
conseil d'état et anciens mal venu et
c'est un euphémisme
dernier point qui nous conduit à
soutenir cette motion de rejet
c'est celui de la dérogation qui serait
donnée en cas de reprise reprise de
là-bas pandémie de pouvoir prendre des
mesures dérogatoires sans intervention
du législateur pendant deux mois
le délai de regard de deux mois avant
l'obligation de prorogation de l'état
d'urgence par la loi prévue dans la
rédaction initiale l'article 2 et six
autres amendements visant à supprimer
cette disposition a été adoptée en
commission avec l'aide du modem de nos
collègues du modem et d'agir le
gouvernement a déposé un amendement pour
l'introduire en séance pour rappel le
dispositif permettait lorsque l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et déclarait sur un
territoire comportant moins de 10% de la
population française de lettres
contraint de requérir sa prorogation par
la loi que delà de deux mois contre 1 -
aujourd'hui les justifications apportées
par le ministre en commission étaient
assez surprenante
on peut le dire évoquant une manière de
ne pas mobiliser les services des
ministères
durant les causes l'aide était est
encore d'éviter de réunir les députés
durant la période festive et estivale
naturellement ces arguments ne tiennent
pas alors que la gestion rh des
ministères assure une présence constante
des moyens de l'état d'une part et que
le député des moeurs mobilisables à tout
moment d'autant plus que dans une année
où le délai du placement en dehors du
pays seront encore limitée d'autre part
donc la réintroduction de cette mesure
manifestement disproportionnée et
inutiles et justifierait également du
rejet préalable du texte
voilà à leurs collègues toutes ces
raisons qui nous amène à se tenir le
rosey préalable de ce texte le redirai
en période de crise
les françaises et les français au besoin
de transparence ont besoin de savoir y
compris qu'on ne sait pas tout mais que
rien ne leur est étranger de cette crise
si à cette condition de transparence nos
chers collègues qu'ils auront confiance
qu'ils ont confiance aux politiques
qu'ils ont confiance à nous
parlementaires et aux gouvernements qui
qui les dirigent
voilà je voulais vous remercier de votre
attention même si je pense que certains
ne partagent pas forcément tous les
arguments en tout cas ces arguments
existent elles questionnent nous
questionnent et
nous invitons à voter notre motion de
rejet
merci mes chers collègues je suis
ministre juge rapporteur
nous en revenons donc aux explications
de vote la motion de rejet préalable
monsieur officia à la parole merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues chers collègues marietta
karamanli le groupe l'est républicain
marche votre à contre cette motion de
rejet préalable car il nous semble que
le texte qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement est un
dispositif qui est pertinent dispositif
de sortie progressive de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et il faut mettre en
place un tel dispositif ce qui n'était
pas une évidence
au départ il y aurait pu y avoir une
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire au regard de la réalité
sanitaire
qui existe encore dans notre pays et que
le ministre olivier ferrand a rappelé
est révoqué tout à l'heure nous avons
dépassé les 105 milles nous sans
sommation 6421 décès nous avons toujours
plus de 20000 contamination par jour
nous avons plus de 8000 67
hospitalisation au cours des sept
derniers jours et une tension dans nos
hôpitaux a particulièrement forte sur
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
et d'outre-mer aussi il nous
apparaissait important non pas de projet
mais bien au regard de la durée de la
crise d'apprendre à sortir
progressivement de cet état d'urgence
est ce que propose ce texte tout en
continuant à avoir des dispositifs qui
permettent de continuer à freiner la
propagation de l'épidémie
tout en retournant à une vie en tout cas
normale le plus vite le plus vite
possible mais les dispositifs de frein
que vous avez évoqué à plusieurs
reprises dans votre dans votre propos
qu'il s'agisse effectivement de
l'article 2 qui permet de mettre en
place un état d'urgence sanitaire
territorialisée ne dépensera pas 10% de
la population au cas où il n'y en aurait
besoin
la question du couvre-feu également sont
des dispositifs qui nous nous semble
nous devons les encadrer nous devons les
discuter bien entendu mais nous devons
pouvoir en avoir besoin au regard
notamment du précédent et de l'été
précédent du retour d'expérience que
nous pouvons en faire au cas où il y
aurait des flambées une reprise
d'épidémie sur certains territoires
au cours de l'été qui vient ce qui fait
que nous rejetons votre proposition nous
pensons qu'il faut plutôt discuter ces
mesures voir comment les encadrer
davantage plutôt que de rejeter tout
simplement ce texte par ailleurs nous
avons grand besoin de dispositifs comme
le pas de sanitaires qui nous permettent
de prendre une activité progressive tout
en mettant une image que se basent
sanitaire ne concerne pas ledit
quotidien
les républicains merci monsieur le
président je m'étonne tout d'abord qui
n'est pas de réponse peut-être à cette
motion de la part du gouvernement je
crois qu'il ya un certain nombre de
points qui ont été soulevées et qui
n'étaient pas évacué d'un revers de main
et qui pourrait appeler quelques
éléments de réponses ou des changes
et si nos débats de cet après-midi se
résume à quelques monologues on sera
encore une fois de plus loin du compte
et je le rappelle avec évidemment un
regret ce texte nul ne conteste pour une
part son utilité si nos concitoyens si
nous mêmes sommes impatients de
recouvrer la liberté de pouvoir
ressortir plus largement plus librement
chacun a bien compris que la maladie
était encore ici bien présente et dans
certaines parties du territoire très
présente effectivement et il est logique
normal que l'exécutif que le
gouvernement puisse ce travail et nul ne
l'a jamais contesté mais ça va très loin
ça va très très loin et je crois que les
questions qui ont été soulevées par
notre collègue karamanli montre la
limite de l'exercice gouvernementale il
faut vous faire confiance pratiquement
les yeux fermés les yeux fermés sur le
pas ce qui est arrivé comme ça deus ex
machina le 3 mai dans la journée à 48
heures de l'examen en commission des
lois sans évidemment l'avis du conseil
d'état sans qu'aucune organisation
extérieure autorité indépendante n'ait
pu se prononcer or se passe ce n'est pas
rien et il ya une levée de boucliers y
compris dans la majorité vous le savez
on peut pas non plus l'évacuer d'un
revers de main sur la territorialisation
et la proclamation possible sur une
partie du territoire de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire la belle affaire on nous dit
qu'effectivement on peut pas réunir le
parlement que les collaborateurs sont
fatigués bah oui ils sont fatigués comme
les députés comme tous nos concitoyens
je n'en doute pas un seul instant mais
le parlement c'est son honneur est là
pour travailler et pour se retrouver et
pour veiller aux libertés publiques
il y a aussi un certain nombre de
questions qui sont soulevées concernant
les données de santé pas de réponse de
votre compte et donc je crois que
pour toutes ces raisons il y a
effectivement urgence a rejeté dès ce
stade le texte et nous soutiendrons la
motion du parti socialiste et de mettre
collègues karamanli merci la parole
était monsieur la tombe pour le groupe
démocrates et démocrates à planter merci
monsieur le président ne pas voter ce
texte ce serait une sortie sèche de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et nous ne
voulons pas nous ne sommes pas
irresponsables donc nous nous souhaitons
nous prononcé en défaveur de cette de
cette motion de rejet
en revanche clairement et je le redirai
dans la discussion générale
nous serons très exigeant sur les
modalités de ce texte très très
exigeants nous avons des points sur
lesquels nous nous sommes déjà exprimé
en commission que nous redéfinir on en
discussion générale nous avons déposé
des amendements en ce sens nous
souhaitons vraiment travailler sur ce
texte est que ce texte soit le plus
clair possible ce texte les français
nous demandent qu'ils soient claires
nous leur devons cette clarté
donc nous rejetterons cette moto une
cette motion de 20 nous voterons contre
cette motion de rejet mais nous
souhaitons que dans ce texte nous
puissions avoir d un véritable dialogue
et que nous puissions avancer c'est ce
sont ces avancées qui feront qu'à
l'arrivée nous prendrons notre décision
en conscience
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très rapidement mais c'est le président
puisque l'essentiel a été rappelé à
juste pour faire une remarque que au nom
du groupe
nous aurions souhaité que la population
qui suit aussi ces débats que le
ministre puisse répondre aux questions
que nous avons soulevés
ce n'était pas forcément des questions à
l'air comme ça c'est des questions
précises des réponses précises que nous
attendons d'ailleurs là la réponse de
notre collègue représentants du modem
exprime bien la tente qui est la nôtre
et l'exigence qui est la nôtre dans le
texte parlementaire donc je ne peux que
le regretter
quelquefois il faut avoir la dignité
pour deux en tout cas nous nous avons
expliqué pour quelles raisons nous avons
porté ce texte de rejet et
qu'effectivement nous nous voterons bien
sûr et qu'on me continueront à exiger
auprès de vous monsieur le ministre et
de gouvernement les réponses précises
merci les parler de monsieur olivier
becht le président pour le groupe
ainsi l'ensemble oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président j'avoue que je
suis assez stupéfait par cette motion de
rejet préalable parce que enfin on est
ici dans un hémicycle ont fait du droit
si cette motion était votée ça voudrait
dire quoi concrètement ça voudrait dire
qu'à partir du 1er juin il n'y a plus
aucun outil pour lutter contre le virus
non mais attendez ça veut dire
concrètement ça veut dire concrètement
que y compris toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement des entreprises que
nous avons malheureusement dû mettre en
place pour les activités qui ne peuvent
pas ouvrir ou qui reprendront
progressivement tout ça serait
impossible
plus de quarantaine aux frontières des
pays qui malheureusement exporte des
variants dont on s'interroge pour
certains sur la résistance aux vaccins
ça veut dire concrètement que nous
mènerions notre pays en danger
donc je pense qu'il ya urgence à rejeter
cette motion de rejet préalable qu'il y
ait des choses à discuter sur le texte
soit mais pour ça il faut que le texte
puisse être en discussion donc la cie
voter la motion de rejet il n'y aurait
pas de discussion de texte veut dire que
le 1er juin
eh bien nous revenons à une situation
totalement normal en faisant comme si il
n'y avait pas encore à peu près 20
milles contamination par jour en faisant
comme si les services de santé n'étaient
pas encore sous tension je trouve cette
attitude de la part du groupe socialiste
assez étonnante
quarante ans jour pour jour après
l'élection du président françois
mitterrand ça montre que de l'esprit de
responsabilité de la certaine idée de la
france qu'il y avait à gouverner ce pays
il ya malheureusement beaucoup de temps
qui se sont écoulées merci mais si la
parole est à monsieur pascal brindeau
pour les occuper et indépendant oui
merci monsieur le président dans
l'argumentation développée par notre
collègue karamanli il y a beaucoup de
choses dans lequel nous pouvons nous
retrouver parce qu'au fond monsieur le
ministre le débat qui est le nôtre
depuis un an maintenant et celui du
choix que fait la france d'un équilibre
institutionnel ou plutôt d'un
déséquilibre institutionnel extrêmement
renforcée pour gérer au mieux la crise
sanitaire et ses conséquences
économiques et sociales et depuis un an
au fond nous sommes nombreux sur les
bancs des différentes oppositions à vous
dire que la solution que vous envisagez
finalement de manière originelle c'est
celui c'est celle de la facilité de la
facilité dans l'arsenal finalement
qu'ils acceptent le parlement de se
dessaisir pour pouvoir prendre un
certain nombre de mesures restrictives
des libertés individuelles et
collectives et c'est la durée la durée
maximale en visage à bhl que vous
demandez à chaque fois que le parlement
vote et la critique
je pense fondamental de notre collègue
du groupe socialiste elles résident cela
en cela de dire non il y a une autre
voie possible qui est celle que le
parlement puisse à période régulière et
non pas par la contrainte mais plutôt
par choix et par co-construction avec le
gouvernement de pouvoir effectivement
établir les mesures qui sont utiles et
nécessaires pour gérer cette crise
sanitaire
alors ne voteront pas la motion de rejet
parce que nous entendons précisément
dans le débat vous montrez que sur un
certain nombre de choses vous faites
fausse route
merci à la parole pour le groupe liberté
et territoires merci monsieur le
président alors j'ai beaucoup apprécié
la prise de parole et la proposition de
motion de rejet mais pas personnellement
puisque notre groupe liberté territoire
dans sa grande majorité soutient cette
motion de rejet
pourtant nous appelons en permanence le
débat dans cet hémicycle
mais malheureusement depuis plus d'un an
maintenant de débat nous n'en avons pas
et malheureusement nous nous subissons
l'exécutif dans toute sa splendeur qui
écrase non seulement les parlementaires
sénateurs et députés mais également les
français depuis le 17 mars 2020 donc je
pense qu'il est urgent de dire stop et
il est urgent en effet de sortir de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ou tout du
moins de permettre aux parlementaires de
faire des propositions concrètes pour
accompagner les françaises et les
français dans la sortie de la crise et
n'ont pas validé parce que si ce qu'il
va se se passait réellement
en fait une mise en place tout à fait
insidieuse d'un état d'urgence permanent
donc je le répète et puis il aurait été
peut-être judicieux pour le ministre ici
présents qu'il y ait des réponses
à toutes les questions qui ont été
exposés en tout cas les français
attendent des réponses donc le groupe
liberté territoire soutient
majoritairement cette motion de rejet
merci pour le groupe
oui entendre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
finalement tout ne serait que la
compréhension de la part des députés et
les mesures prises
finalement ce serait bien légère est
uniquement fait pour faciliter la vie
pendant la sortie de la crise sanitaire
alors déjà pointant que sortie de la
crise sanitaire me semblent être une
comment dire quelque chose d'annoncé qui
me paraît périlleux qui ne paraît plus
répondre malheureusement à l'agenda
politique décidée par monsieur mâcon cas
l'état réel de la pandémie en france et
entend le monde et en plus je n'ai pas
cette lecture moi j'y vois plutôt et
c'est un problème nouvel épisode de
l'état d'exception dans lequel le pays
est plongé depuis maintenant plus d'un
an
et d'ailleurs quand je regarde le fait
que la seule différence entre le régime
d'état d'urgence sanitaire les jeunes de
sortie puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit s'agit du même texte que la loi
de juillet 2020 c'est l'impossibilité
décrit décrété un confinement strict
avec l'origine de la sortie on voit bien
que entre ça et ce qui est proposé il ya
toute latitude pour justement un état
d'exception qui devient permanent sans
compter que il ya plein de respect de
cette loi on l'a vu en commission qui
sont mal ficelés je pense aussi à
l'amendement du gouvernement sur la
question du pass sanitaires on y
reviendra
je pense aussi aux dérogations sur le
code du travail qui sont proposés qui me
semble est une fois de plus une vision
de sortie crise économique et sociale
qui serait surtout sur le pwa justement
du monde du travail enfin je voulais
dire par rapport à nos collègues qui
pensent que une motion de rejet n'a pas
lieu d'être
ça serait peut-être plus le cas si on
acceptait de débattre réellement du
fonds pour notre part sur les dix sept
amendements que nous proposons je viens
d'apprendre que huit étaient
irrecevables et qu'il s'agissait
justement deux d'amendements proposant
des alternatives à la stratégie proposée
ce qui aurait dû être aussi
au coeur de notre débat nous voterons
pour la motion de rejet merci après
l'ultime orateurs inscrits monsieur peu
pour le groupe gdr s'est pas la parole
oui merci merci monsieur le président on
aura l'occasion tout à l'heure dans la
discussion générale d'en dire un peu
plus sur les rentrées plus en détail sur
cette proposition de loi mais nous
voterons cette motion de rejet déjà pour
au moins de principe contrairement à ce
qu'a dit monsieur betsch tout à l'heure
la responsabilité avoir le sens de la
responsabilité c'est rechercher
l'efficacité
or je ne pense pas que et la
démonstration a été faite que la mise
entre parenthèses de la démocratie le
retrait des pouvoirs du parlement dans
la conduite de ce crise et était un gage
d'efficacité et je remarque par ailleurs
que dans beaucoup de pays voisins
il n'en a pas été là mais de la méthode
de l'état d'urgence n'a pas été retenu
et que les parlements les assemblées
élues ont délibéré pris des décisions
collectivement quand il fallait prendre
les décisions collectivement et je pense
que pour être en responsabilité et
rechercher l'efficacité il faut que les
décisions que soient consentis pour
qu'elles soient consentis faut qu'elle
soit débattue et qu'elle fasse l'objet
d'une délibération collective et ce
n'est pas un conseil de défense dont
personne ne connaît exactement les
délibérations et la nature des débats
qui peut se suffire pour diriger et
conduire cette crise on l'a bien vu il
ya beaucoup d'erreurs qui ont été
commises qui aurait pu s'en douter très
évitée même si il n'est pas facile de
gouverner en cette période
je leur dis à chaque fois mais qui
aurait pu être évité si on avait été au
contraire dans la recherche du débat et
de la délibération collective alors il
ya d'autres raisons qui nous inquiète
dans cette proposition de loi les
coquerelles viens de parler du volet
social qui est beaucoup d'autres
questions qui ont été posées par
marietta karamanli et donc pour toutes
ces raisons nous voterons en faveur de
cette motion de rejet merci donc les
orateurs se sont exprimés je vais mettre
voir cette motion de rejet
ceux qui souhaite son adoption lèvres
même la main et faites votre des
lectures qui est contre l'adoption de la
motion est rejetée nous poursuivons nos
des débats par la discussion générale
monsieur bouffier chars la parole chacun
des orateurs disposera de cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues voilà maintenant
plus d'un an que le monde entier notre
pays sont plongés dans cette crise
sanitaire particulièrement violente
voici maintenant plus d'un an quand
responsabilités nous prenons dans le
respect de notre constitution est de
notre droit
les mesures adéquates et proportionnées
pour agir pour protéger des vies pour
enrayer la propagation de ce virus et
permettre à nos personnels soignants de
réaliser leur travail
bien entendu nous savons les efforts que
tout s'est tu touches un représente mais
elles sont nécessaires au moment même où
nous parlons
l'épidémie est encore une réalité du
quotidien notre pays même si nous
arrivons à entrevoir des perspectives
positives grâce aux mesures que nous
avons prises ces derniers mois grâce au
civisme des français bien entendu aussi
et grâce à la montée en puissance de la
campagne vaccinale
c'est cette situation qui nous amène
aujourd'hui à discuter d'un projet de
loi qui vient non pas prorogé une
nouvelle fois l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais proposer un cadre de sortie
progressive et proportionnée au regard
de la situation sanitaire économique et
social nous tenons à saluer la décision
prise par le gouvernement de ne pas
proroger l'état d'urgence sanitaire au
delà du 1er juin et de rentrer à partir
du 2 juin et ce jusqu'au 31 octobre dans
une période de transition dans une
période de sortie progressive de l'état
d'urgence cette décision était souhaitée
par nombre d'entre nous nous sommes en
effet convaincus que face à la durée
exceptionnelle de cette crise sanitaire
nous devons réussir à apporter un cadre
d'action proportionnée et efficace en
dehors de l'état d'urgence un cadre qui
nous permettent de retourner
progressivement à la vie d'avant tout en
gardant bien des leviers d'action juste
et proportionnée
c'est ce que ce projet de loi propose
bien entendu plusieurs points de débat
existe et nous les discuteront au cours
des heures qui viennent
j'en retiendrai 5 que nous avons déjà eu
à discuter en commission des lois
le premier concerne la date de fin de
cette période de transition qui est
fixée au 31 octobre
si je comprends certaines propositions
je suis convaincu que nous devons
aujourd'hui maintenir la date du 31
octobre qui est une date pertinentes et
proportionnée au regard des prévisions
de la campagne vaccinale ces dates
permet par ailleurs de donner une
lisibilité claire aux français et à
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activité
économique quant à la gestion de la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le deuxième point de débat concerne la
mise en place du pass sanitaires nous
savions depuis plusieurs mois que nous
aurions à avoir ce débat et nous
souhaitons qu'il ait lieu si nous avons
besoin de ce dispositif pour redémarrer
un certain nombre d'activités
nous devons nous nous devons de définir
très clairement le périmètre des
activités qui peuvent se voir appliquer
le pass sanitaire nous posons une ligne
rouge
cependant le bassin leader ne pourra
jamais concerné les activités de la vie
quotidienne en cela je tiens à saluer
l'amendement de la présidente de la
commission des lois à yann groupes
privés que nous avons adoptée en
commission et qui apporte une réponse à
cette exigence
le troisième point débat concerne le
couvre-feu qui actuellement ne peut être
déclenché qu'en période d'état d'urgence
sanitaire si nous comprenons le maintien
de ce dispositif au regard de la période
sanitaire actuelle qui est plus dégradée
à la même période que l'année précédente
nous saluons le fait que le dispositif
soit bien défini dans la durée le temps
notamment qu'il ne puisse pas excéder 30
juin 2021
nous apporterons cependant une précision
qui attention quand pas son application
à partir du 9 juin 2021 et nous
attendons des réponses précises de la
part du gouvernement concernant la
mécanique de mise en place et de
contrôle de ce dispositif qui demeure un
dispositif exorbitant de droit commun
particulièrement grave même pour un mois
le troisième point de débat concerne
l'article 2 qui ouvre la possibilité au
gouvernement de déclencher pour une
durée de deux mois une période d'état
d'urgence sanitaire territorialisée au
regard du retour d'expérience que nous
pouvons faire de l'été 2020 et de la
situation sanitaire actuelle ce
dispositif nous paraît nécessaire à
condition d'être parfaitement encadré et
contrôlé par le parlement le
gouvernement souhaite rétablir le
dispositif qui n'avaient pas été
validées par la commission des lois
nous le comprenons mais au groupe le
groupe la république en marche opposera
avec le rapporteur jean-pierre pont je
tiens à saluer le travail un compromis
afin que nous puissions nous entendre
sur la mise en place de ce dispositif et
du contrôle du parlement
le cinquième point principal de débat
que je retiens concerne la conservation
des données
je tiens à vous alerter mes chers
collègues que le texte que nous
discutons aujourd'hui n'a pas pour objet
de prévoir les modalités de renforcement
de notre souveraineté numérique sujet
auquel nous sommes toutes et tous
attaché ni même de revoir les modalités
de fonctionnement du smvs nous aurons le
débat ici dans cet hémicycle essayons de
ne pas perdre deux objectifs 1 ne
fragilisons pas nos dispositifs de
conservation des données sanitaires et
deux gardes ont bien à l'esprit que nous
aurons besoin des données issues de
cette crise pour les travaux nos
chercheurs travaux qui nous permettront
de tirer tous les enseignements de cette
crise sanitaire et d'améliorer nos
politiques de soins
en conclusion mes chers collègues la
crise sanitaire que nous vivons est
unique et elle aura marqué durablement
chacune et chacun d'entre nous nous ne
l'oublierons jamais dans les semaines
qui viennent
nous avons l'occasion d'amorcer un début
de retour à la vie normale
une étape qui ne nous exempte pas
cependant de nos responsabilités aussi
soyons lecteurs je vous remercie
merci est la parole est à m le flux
gosselin pour les républicains qui
disposent également de cinq minutes
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur mais
mes chers collègues il est important de
se retrouver aujourd'hui ici pour
assurer la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire puisque début juin nous serons
enfin sorti de cette étape exorbitante
du droit commun de cet état d'exception
que nous vivons déjà depuis trop de moi
les france la france et les français
s'en sont impatients de retrouver leur
liberté pour autant la situation est
encore grave chacun le sait le mesure
est particulièrement un parti de
gouvernement comme le nôtre il est bien
entendu que le gouvernement a besoin
d'actes a besoin de texte pour agir et
continuer à être présent et faire son
devoir et le travail que l'on attend de
lui pour autant
le texte qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui est un texte qui n'est pas à
la hauteur de ce que l'on peut attendre
en réalité c'est un texte canada dry un
texte qui ressemble à la sortie qui
ressemble à la liberté recouvrée
mais qui ne l'est pas qui ne l'est pas
car à l'exception du confinement général
en réalité il n'ya quasiment pas de
changement par rapport à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est une fois de
plus la démonstration que la
banalisation se fait de l'utilisation de
l'état d'urgence de sa sortie qui était
supposée être en sifflet en ciseaux en
biseau chacun le lieu vivra comme il le
veut mais qui n'est pas en réalité une
sortie réelle de l'état d'exception
puisque jusqu'au 31 octobre 31 octobre
c'est un délai très long il sera
toujours possible d'actionner un nombre
important très important de levier
pendant pratiquement enfin moi et ce
depuis le mois de mars 2021
c'est un délai long et qui ne permet pas
les clauses de revoyure telle qu'elle
avait été demandé à de nombreuses
reprises par les parlementaires et c'est
sur plusieurs bancs y compris d'ailleurs
sur des sièges de la majorité
c'est vrai que c'est un peu casse pieds
ce parlement qui veut régulièrement se
réunir c'est vrai que c'est un peu casse
pieds monsieur le ministre ce parlement
qui veut empêcher les agents publics les
membres des cabinets de partir en
vacances pour reprendre l'argumentaire
que vous aviez développé il ya quelques
jours non le parlement il est là
évidemment pour agir pour contrôler pour
évaluer il est là pour faire son travail
et il n'y a aucune difficulté à le
réunir et il est bien dommage qu'une
fois encore malgré les événements nous
soyons sous le diktat d'une certaine
façon de l'exécutif qui ne veut pas
écouter davantage le parlement
et puis quid de ce pass sanitaires
quid de cet amendement qui est tombé du
chapeau le 3 mai sans avis donc du
conseil d'état sans que la cnil ne
puisse elle même se prononcer puisque
elle le fait mercredi donc en commission
des lois la semaine dernière on a
examiné un amendement qui n'a pas été
examiné par le conseil d'état ni par la
cnil et qui ne le sera que mardi après
le vote de ce soir ou demain c'est bien
c'est la démocratie version
macron et version majorité et j'avoue
que je goûte peu le sujet on y reviendra
quid d'un grand rassemblement ne sait
même pas quid des textes qui gère le
quotidien ou pas le quotidien ça va nous
rappeler les bons souvenirs de
l'essentiel ou du non essentiel en tout
cas cet obscur abscons et il faut y
revenir quid de ce couvre-feu qui va
jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
alors qu'en principe le couvre-feu n'est
possible que dans l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
vous voyez bien qu'en réalité on ne sort
pas vraiment de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
et puis quid de cet état d'urgence
sanitaire qui peut être provoquée qui
peut être annoncés dans 10 % du
territoire et pendant une période de
deux mois
là aussi on évince le parlement circulez
ya rien à voir
deux mois c'est un mois de plus que dans
la situation actuelle qui pose déjà bien
des questions et puis quid aussi de la
protection des données 2-2 santé
l'ensemble sera versée au service
national
pardon des données de santé au système
national des données de santé donc pour
une durée de 20 ans avec des données qui
sont seulement pseudonyme ise et non pas
anonymisées je rappelle que la
pseudonymie nations permet sous
certaines conditions de revenir en
arrière et donc de retrouver qui sont
les détenteurs de ces données de de
santé il y alla donc un vrai sujet ce
vrai sujet mérite une attention
particulière car si l'on résume il y a
cinq points essentiels sur huit articles
et encore je passe sous silence les
éléments qui concerne la loi électorale
pour les prochaines élections
départementales et régionales donc il ya
un vrai sujet ce texte est porteur de
vraies difficultés et une fois donc en
une fois encore pardon il ne permet pas
de concilier comme nous le souhaitons et
comme nos concitoyens l'attendent de
concilier les libertés individuelles et
les libertés publiques avec la
nécessaire bien sûr protection de la
santé publique
c'est cet équilibre qui fait défaut et
j'espère que nous arriverons à nous
entendre mieux que sur d'autres textes
jusqu'à présent je vous remercie merci
nous venons pression de monsieur
philippe la tombe pour le mouvement
démocrate et les démocrates et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues et dans la tempête et le bruit
la clarté reparaît grandit à travers ses
verres victor hugo exprime ce que nos
concitoyens nous disent depuis des mois
avec leurs mots ils demandent une parole
publique cohérente et claire il n'est
pas un jour où il ne nous demande pas de
remonter au gouvernement qu'il le soit
également
après des mois de sacrifice d'abnégation
de souffrances et d'efforts les français
souhaitent retrouver une vie normale
oh bien sûr ils ont bien compris que la
situation restait tendue que le virus
circule encore et continuent à faire des
victimes
mais ils veulent pouvoir prévoir
construire anticipé et ce malgré des
incertitudes des conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise nous
devons les entendre et les accompagner
en rendant ce texte clair cohérent et
intelligible c'est d'ailleurs dans la
constitution une prérogative
parlementaire et quant à la rédaction de
la loi un principe à valeur
constitutionnelle pour le groupe
mouvement démocrate et démocrate
apparenté ce texte nécessite en séance
un travail particulier sur trois points
trois points incontournables sur
lesquels nous souhaitons véritablement
avancer ce sont ceux déjà largement
évoqué en commission des lois pour
lesquelles les travaux doivent se
poursuivre en séance et notamment doit
être examinée avec objectivité
il s'agit de la date de sortie prévue
par le texte du délai accordé l'exécutif
pour les éventuels confinement locaux et
enfin du pass sanitaires la date de
sortie prévue par le texte au 30 octobre
est trop lointaine et peu cohérente peu
cohérente avec les annonces faites par
le président de la république et ensuite
par le gouvernement le fait que la
vaccination progresse avec pour objectif
que tout français souhaitant une
vacciner le soit avant la fin de l'été
plaide pour une date plus proche
nos compatriotes veulent sortir vite de
cet état exceptionnel
nous parlementaires aussi nous vous
demandons d'avancer cette date au 30
septembre 2021
nous prenons l'engagement de revenir si
le besoin s'en fait sentir à n'importe
quel moment pour examiner un texte en
enfin l'ensemble des oppositions à
déposer des amendements sur ce point
cherchez la concorde à travers une date
avancée serait donc un signe fort donné
aux français
quant à l'union nationale réclamaient
depuis si longtemps sur la possibilité
de décréter déconfinement locaux jusqu'à
deux mois dans le gouvernement s'en
saisir les parlementaires
nous nous réjouissons du travail fait en
commission pour ramener ce délai à un
mois dans le respect des prérogatives
constitutionnelles des parlementaires là
encore en responsabilité au cas où la
situation sanitaire l'exigerait nous
devrions être saisi en urgence d'un
texte durant l'été nous serions présents
comme nous l'avons toujours été
nous pourrions éventuellement en lieu et
place de l'amendement proposé par le
gouvernement à ce sujet qui revient in
extenso sur la demande vont voter en
commission
prévoir une exception pour les mois de
juillet et d'août nous pensons servent
sincèrement que nous pouvons avancer
ensemble sur ce sujet dernier point le
pass sanitaire qui va encore sans nul
doute occuper de longues minutes voire
des heures de notre débat comme indiqué
en commission notre groupe soutient se
passe sanitaire contrairement aux
passeports vaccinale évoqué précédemment
se passe et respectueux des libertés de
chacun pourvu qu'il soit réservé des
événements spécifiques clairement exclu
pour les actes de la vie courante
restaurants cinémas magasin est
clairement défini par la loi
nous ne souhaitons pas un texte vague
qui ne fasse que renvoyer à des décrets
ceux ci sont essentiels certes mais dans
un cadre prévu imposée par la loi et
donc défini par nous les parlementaires
dont c'est le rôle de fait nous avons
déposé des amendements pour définir les
concepts de grands rassemblements en
décidant d'une jauge minimale ce qui
aura pour les français la force de la
clarté et d'une densité maximale tir en
cela les enseignements des différentes
procédures de mon conseil d'état
notamment concernant les lieux de culte
de même la notion de certains lieux est
trop flou nous en souhaitant une
définition plus claire et discuter du
cas particulier des établissements de
nuit avec l'amendement de christ de
notre collègue christophe blanchet pour
éviter un nouveau psychodrame
généralisée comme celui que nous avons
pu connaître sur les commerces
essentielles ou non essentiels nous
avons le droit d'apprendre des
expériences passées et nous devons
éviter nous ridiculiser par des
protocoles ou des directives trop flou
et sujette à interprétation permanente
ces points essentiels et ont été posées
à nouveau il en reste deux autres
d'importance moindre mais non
négligeable le premier concerne
l'intégration dont la cnds des
informations collectées dans le cadre de
la crise de l'aco vide
nous sommes favorables à l'utilisation
des données dans des entrepôts de
données de santé sécurisé souverain pour
permettre les recherches sur cette
pandémie
ces éventuels traitements aux vaccins à
venir et sur les conséquences en suivi
longitudinal pour nos concitoyens il n'y
a pas de débat sur ce point soyons
clairs néanmoins les données de traçage
des quatre contacts des potentiels
risotto donc risque de contamination
elles ont été obtenues auprès de nos
concitoyens en leur promettant qu'elle
disparaîtrait au plus tard le 31
décembre 2021 nous allons déposer un
amendement pour garantir la date
initialement prévue
car l'accès à la plupart de ces données
restent possibles par d'autres canaux
dans le cnds enfin dernier point de
vigilance le respect du droit européen
et sa nécessaire intégration dans notre
droit notre groupe où le savez est
profondément attachée à l'europe et au
travail de ses instances ne surent
transpose ne surent transposons pas les
textes dans notre droit la notion de
certificats de rétablissement doit être
préférée au mot un document attestant du
rétablissement interne européen existe
recouvre des délais et est précis
utilisons le immédiatement ainsi mes
chers collègues le groupe démocrate sera
très attentif au débat de ce soir est
sans doute de demain soir c'est à la
lumière des avancées qui auront peut
être travaillée adoptée durant nos
débats que le groupe se positionnera sur
ce texte
si je ne partage pas l'intégralité de
son oeuvre ne reviennent les mots de
françois mitterrand la clarté et la
forme la plus difficile du courage c'est
ce courage là que nous devons avoir ce
soir je vous remercie
merci la parole est à marietta karamanli
donc la parole et de brides en beige
taupe pour le groupe agir ensemble
suppose également de cinq minutes
m
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur meschers colette
sommes donc réunis ici ce soir pour
discuter du projet de loi sur la gestion
de la sortie de la crise sanitaire
nous le faisons au moment où nous avons
entamé le troisième déconfinement alors
que notre pays compte malheureusement
déjà près de 5,7 millions de personnes
qui ont été contaminées par la cobi 19
sont les chiffres des personnes testées
il est probable qu'il y en ait
malheureusement beaucoup plus notamment
les cas asymptomatiques qu'il n'aurait
pas été testés et nous avons hélas plus
de 106 mille morts
aujourd'hui autant de familles
endeuillées et autant malheureusement de
kovy de long tous ceux qui ont été
atteints par cette maladie et qui en ont
encore malheureusement des symptômes
persistants à cela il faut ajouter
maintenant depuis bientôt un an une
série de mesures restrictives de liberté
liberté de circulation liberté également
de commerce liberté de réunion pour
certains ça c'est une période de liberté
de culte est une somme assez
astronomique de dépenses qui ont été
faites pour compenser toutes les
activités qui ont été fermés c'est
d'ailleurs à l'honneur du gouvernement
de les avoir mises avoir su protéger la
société
mais il ya évidemment un coût important
pour nos finances publiques puisque avec
les mesures d'indemnisation et les
mesures de relance
nous aurons quasiment dépensé 400
milliards d'euros de plus que ce qui
était prévu dans nos budgets
depuis il ya bientôt un an la question
qui se pose ce soir est de savoir si
nous pouvons sortir de manière sereine
de cette crise sanitaire bien sûr nous
souhaiterions tous pouvoir retrouver
cette vie normale le plus rapidement
possible mais la réalité des chiffres
est là
nous avons encore à peu près 20 milles
contamination par jour nous avons une
tension importante dans nos systèmes de
soin et particulièrement en réanimation
et puis nous avons malheureusement aussi
encore 200 à 300 morts par jour relâché
des efforts comme ça de manière brutale
serait évidemment irresponsable parce
que ça risquerait de nous amener une
quatrième vague et pour toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont quelques plans de
vacances pour l'été
ce serait le risque de se retrouver
recond fine et le moment venu
il est donc particulièrement important
que nous puissions conserver des outils
monsieur le ministre qui permettent de
freiner l'épidémie
pendant encore quelques semaines voire
quelques mois et s'assurer que la
vaccination qui avancent lentement
bien sûr on souhaiterait qu'elles
avancent plus vite mais cela dépend
évidemment du rythme de production des
vaccins et ça dépend aussi de la volonté
des français de se faire vacciner il
faudra que chacun joue le jeu si nous
souhaitons arriver à cette fameuse
immunité collective
il ya donc dans cette loi des outils de
freinage
vous en avez cité quelques-uns et puis
des outils qui permettent de s'assurer
et bien que le ne nous continuons pas
dans les grands rassemblements
parmi ces outils il y en a deux
importants le premier c'est bien entendu
le pass sanitaires je veux dire que le
groupe agir ensemble et plutôt
favorables aux pass sanitaire tel qu'il
est proposé aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement c'est dire dire ce n'est
pas une obligation de vaccination c'est
la capacité si l'on est vacciné et si
l'on n'est pas vacciné d'avoir un test
pcr négatif tout ça dans une application
qui permettent de participer soit à un
voyage lorsqu'on veut franchir une
frontière ou de particuliers un grand
événement
plus de 1000 personnes ça nous paraît
être une jauge particulièrement
raisonnable le maintien du couvre-feu
même à des heures plus avancée de la
nuit
et évidemment peu sympathique c'est vrai
mais en même temps ça fait partie des
mesures qui marche pour limiter la
propagation de l'épidémie
et donc nous considérons que c'est
encore un mal nécessaire pour les
quelques mois qui nous reste enfin je
voudrais conclure monsieur le ministre
nous voterons le groupe agir ensemble
cette loi nous pensons que lé
nécessaires en l'état actuel il est
certain que nous nous interrogeons bien
évidemment sur la question de la
stratégie si par extraordinaire ce que
nous ne souhaitons pas il devait y avoir
une nouvelle vague de qu'ovide qui
arrivait en dépit des mesures qui
étaient prises et nous contraindrait à
nouvel état d'urgence sanitaire
alors monsieur le ministre vous le savez
le groupe agir ensemble a été clair nous
souhaiterions dans ces cas là qu'il soit
constaté l'échec des stratégies de
freinage du virus et que l'on puisse
s'attaquer au coeur du problème c'est à
dire la stratégie d'éradication celle
que nous soutenons maintenant depuis
sept mois la stratégie zéro co vide qui
permettent cette fois ci des mesures un
peu plus dur mais qui permettent de
manière plus courtes d'avoir des
résultats plus efficace c'est-à-dire
arriver à une stratégie zéro co vide
je vous remercie merci la parole est le
monsieur pascal brindeau pour le groupe
u10 et indépendant
[Musique]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur au fond
on a sans doute le sentiment collectif
d'être revenu un an en arrière parce que
malheureusement le virus a connu de
nouvelles vagues qui ont imposé le
retour de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
revenus un an en arrière aussi puisque
notre débat de ce jour est celui de
savoir dans quelles conditions nous
pouvons sortir de cet état d'urgence
sanitaire
et quelle est la voie parlementaire et
gouvernementale dans un certain nombre
de domaines se sanitaire évidemment mais
aussi pour traiter des conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
sanitaire sur un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens et je le disais tout à
l'heure au fond le reproche fondamental
que l'on puisse vous faire c'est le
choix de la facilité le choix de la
facilité du systématique de l'ensemble
finalement des mesures que l'exécutif
peut prendre y compris part parce que le
parlement se serait dessaisie de ses
prérogatives
la facilité la systématisation des
ordonnances qui sont prises à ce titre
et puis la facilité des délais
c'est-à-dire de prévoir ces mesures qui
ne sont pas des mesures détaillées
d'urgence mais qui ne sont pas non plus
des mesures de droit commun et bien au
plus loin possible afin d'anticiper
heureusement ou malheureusement une
prolongation d'une situation sanitaire
qui ne serait pas redevenu satisfaisante
pour permettre à nos concitoyens de
retrouver une vie plus normale trois
problématiques sont posés en fait par le
texte une problématique institutionnels
encore une fois celle de la place du
parlement et du déséquilibre trop
important à notre sens entre l'exécutif
et effectivement le pouvoir législatif
je crois que ça a été rappelé par
ailleurs par notre collègue stéphane peu
dans d'autres grandes démocraties
compris dans des démocraties européennes
un proche de nous ce choix là n'a pas
été fait et on a respecté en fait
l'équilibré des pouvoirs habituel dans
nos démocraties qui veut que la loi ça
procède à un moment donné du parlement
parce que c'est l'expression du débat
démocratique
un problème juridique ensuite parce que
nous le voyons et nous le voyons encore
plus clairement dans ce texte avec des
amendements qui font que les mesures de
confinement partiel pourraient être
réintroduites si elle concerne les
départements ou des régions avec moins
de 10% de la population française ou la
prolongation du couvre-feu et bien nous
passons d'un système d'état d'urgence
qui est un droit totalement dérogatoire
à une prolongation de l'état d'urgence
ce texte ne porte pas ce nom là
puisqu'il s'agit d'une sortie de l'état
d'urgence mais en réalité nous sommes
dans la plénitude des mesures liées à
l'état d'urgence sanitaire lorsqu'on
ajoute ces deux éléments là aux autres
éléments qui sont par ailleurs contenues
dans le texte et cela nous pose un vrai
problème
et puis ensuite il ya la question de
l'acceptabilité par nos concitoyens qui
nous saluons évidemment notre
responsabilité collective leur
responsabilité individuelle et
collective qui ont su effectivement
respecté toutes les interdictions toutes
les précautions que l'état a pu leur
demander pour effectivement protéger au
mieux l'ensemble de nos concitoyens de
la propagation de ce de ce virus mais
pour qu'ils aient une acceptabilité
encore
de ces mesures il faut qu'ils en
comprennent le sens il faut par exemple
que ce ne soit pas la voie réglementaire
qui permette de déterminer dans quelles
conditions le pass sanitaire sera mise
en oeuvre et nous avons des amendements
pour préciser cela
il faut effectivement qu'il ne concerne
pas les actes de la vie quotidienne
mais quand il s'agit de grands
rassemblements par exemple il faut
préciser que ces grands rassemblements
sont ceux où la densité de population
présente instantanément sur un lieu est
bien fait en sorte qu'il y à des risques
potentiels supplémentaires de
propagation du virus et que c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons
alors à nos concitoyens de faire état
soit de la vaccination soit d'un test
pcr négatif soit et c'est une question
que j'ai à l'endroit du ministre de la
santé je lui reposerait donc tout à
l'heure s'agissant des tests
sérologiques positif pour savoir si
effectivement le fait d'avoir contracté
le virus et donc de développer des
anticorps est aujourd'hui une garantie
et peut rentrer donc dans le cadre de ce
pass sanitaire en fait finalement ce que
nous reprochons est la raison pour
laquelle le groupe udi votre à contre le
texte majoritairement aux s'abstiendra
c'est une vision par trop coercitives de
la gestion de la crise sanitaire
je vous remercie merci monsieur nadeau
la parole est à vous monsieur paul molac
pour le groupe liberté et territoires
votre président sur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur
mes chers collègues depuis novembre 2015
et l'instauration de l'état d'urgence
pour lutter contre le terrorisme les
français ont davantage vécu faisant
régime d'exception que sous le régime
ordinaire
ce constat n'est pas forcément fait pour
me réjouir le nouveau régime de sortie
de l'état d'urgence que vous nous
proposez demeure un état d'urgence qui
nous dit son nom il vient prolonger pour
cinq mois supplémentaires la succession
de régimes d'exception dans lesquelles
nous vivons depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire ont regardé possibilités dont
dispose de droit commun du code de la
santé publique exprimée de nombreux soit
par notre groupe la prolongation sans
limites de cet état d'exception nous
inquiète et elle amène un
dessaisissement des pouvoirs du
parlement et donc j'aurais tendance à
penser que si nous sommes ici les
représentants du peuple sait que c'est
pour quelque chose et que donc la
moindre des choses
évidemment que tout cela soit qu'on
construit avec le parlement beaucoup de
français supporte de moins en moins les
restrictions qui sont parfois difficiles
à comprendre
on doit l'admettre un couvre-feu à 19
heures dans une région le virus ne
circule absolument pas et
fondamentalement difficile à concevoir
et à accepter
selon le calendrier de vaccination
défini 30 millions de français soit les
deux tiers de la population adulte
seront vaccinés d'ici l'été
la vaccination semble faire obstacle à
la propagation du virus dans ce cas
pourquoi poursuivre cet état de sorties
pour une durée aussi éloignés que le 30
octobre il y à un véritable problème de
confiance
derrière ces régime de restriction de
liberté
la mesure de couvre feu que vous
souhaitez prolonger ou le système
d'attestation qui a déjà valu une à nos
concitoyens plus de 2,2 millions de
verbalisation se fonde sur une suspicion
permanente pourtant la grande majorité
de la population est vertueuse la lutte
contre la pandémie nécessite pourtant la
responsabilisation et la co construction
d'autres démocraties européennes
affrontent l'épidémie en traitant leur
population avec davantage de confiance
par ailleurs le gouvernement ne semble
toujours pas avoir pris la mesure de la
nécessité de respecter le parlement
comme toujours le président de la
république décide le gouvernement
exécute et le parlement et les élus
locaux mettent en oeuvre
pourtant ce n'est pas le rôle du
parlement pas plus que des élus locaux
d'ailleurs qui sont des élus du peuple
la volonté du gouvernement de repousser
à deux mois la possibilité de prononcer
un état d'urgence territorialisée sans
consulter le parlement en attestent
nous nous félicitons que cette mesure
était supprimée en commission et
espérons que suffisamment de voix
s'élèveront pour qu'elle ne soit pas
rétabli en séance nous notons un point
positif
il semblerait que le gouvernement
commence à prendre conscience de la
nécessité d'adapter les mesures aux
contextes locaux
après plus d'un an de mesures décrétées
presque exclusivement de manière
uniforme sur l'ensemble des territoires
mieux vaut tard que jamais dans le
détail des mesures
nous nous opposons à l'inspiration n'a
pas sanitaires même s'il s'applique
seulement pour des événements précis
l'instauration du passé iter crée un
dangereux précédent
un amendement bienvenue de la présidente
de la commission des lois a été adopté
pour préciser explicitement que le pass
ne peut être réclamée pour d'autres buts
que ceux prévu c'est à dire qu'il ne
pourra pas être réclamés dans la vie
quotidienne pour aller au restaurant ou
au cinéma par exemple toutefois qu'en
sera-t-il si l'épidémie se prolonge
qu'en sera-t-il lors de la prochaine
épidémie le parlement ne peut ouvrir une
boîte de pandore qui amènera plus tard à
généraliser ce type de pratiques
discriminatoires à l'ensemble des
aspects de la vie des citoyens
nous nous opposons la prolongation d'un
couvre-feu jusqu'au 31 juillet 30 juin
il nous paraît invraisemblable de
conserver ces mesures attentatoires à le
plus fondamental des libertés celle de
se déplacer alors que le confinement
s'accélère et que les bars et
restaurants ou salles de sport vont
ouvrir le fait que vous proposiez que
l'état puisse s'opposer au choix du lieu
retenu par une personne pour son
placement en quarantaine est un autre
exemple attestant du manque de confiance
nous ne pouvons accepter que le
gouvernement puisse continuer d'
ordonner la fermeture de catégories
entières d'établissement
alors que les commerces ont payé un
lourd tribut lors de cette crise et
prennent toutes les mesures sanitaires
nécessaires pour accueillir le public en
sécurité il faut laisser la possibilité
d'ouvrir moyennant la mise en place de
mesures sanitaires strictes pour
l'accueil des clients concernant le
droit du travail
le texte prévoit la prolongation du
contrat était en octobre de la
possibilité pour un employeur d'imposer
la prise de congés de ses salariés à
n'importe quel moment et aggravent cette
mesure en portant de six à huit le
nombre de jours concernés
ceci alors même que se profilent
première véritable période de vacances
pour les travailleurs nous ne comprenons
pas ce qui justifie cette mesure
combattue par la totalité des syndicats
enfin concernant les mesures
d'adaptation pour les élections
régionales
si nous soutenons ces mesures
nécessaires pourquoi avoir supprimé en
commission la mesure prévoyant que le
service public à la charge d'organiser
des débats entre les candidats qui
apporterait de sérieuses garanties
je termine monsieur le président en
définitive la grande majorité des
membres du groupe liberté et territoires
votera contre ce texte
encore bien trop restrictif et
attentatoire aux libertés pour un
présumé régime de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
je vous remercie merci la parole est
désormais monsieur eric coquerel pour la
france atomise le président bonjour
chers collègues j'aurais aimé dire
aimait dire messieurs les ministres mais
je vois que monsieur verront n'est déjà
plus là je doute que le projet de loi
que nous examinons soit celui de la
sortie de la crise sanitaire
il est par contre assurément celui de la
prolongation d'un état d'exception car
non seulement ce texte vous permet de
prolonger l'état d'urgence jusqu'au 31
août
mais en plus il proroge un régime
exceptionnel jusqu en octobre
on ne peut pas prendre cela à la légère
un exécutif quel qu'il soit au nom de ce
qu'il estime être l'efficacité de son
action a naturellement tendance à
s'exonérer des freins mis à son pouvoir
c'est encore plus vrai dans la vème
république
voilà pourquoi montesquieu a érigé la
séparation des trois pouvoirs comme
remède aux abus pour qu'on ne puisse
abuser du pouvoir et quitte il faut que
la part à disposition des choses le
pouvoir
avec le pouvoir cette disposition des
choses le pouvoir arrête le pouvoir
c'est l'état de droit
c'était à droit auquel pour des
questions sécuritaires et maintenant
sanitaires vous vous êtes habitué à
substituer un état d'urgence quasi
permanent c'est à terme inverser la
règle traditionnelle de la république
qui veut que la liberté soit le principe
et sa restriction l'exception si je
rappelle des évidences ici c'est
qu'elles ne le sont plus pour
gouvernement voilà pourquoi chers
collègues c'est aux pouvoirs législatifs
à nous d'y veiller
cette facilité ce déséquilibre de la
balance entre liberté et sécurité vous
fait en plus commettre des erreurs car
depuis un an
vous refusez toute proposition
alternative au confinement et vous vous
comptez finalement contenté finalement
de régler le bouton sur plus ou moins de
restriction de liberté confinement plus
ou moins drastiques plus ou moins de
contrôle des déplacements plus ou moins
de couvre feu vous vous contentez de
changer les restrictions de degrés selon
l'humeur du moment alors qu'il ya de
quoi douter sérieusement de l'efficacité
dans le temps de la nature de ces
mesures par exemple ce couvre feu
extrêmement liberty cible que vous
maniez avec tant de facilité
nous n'avons contrairement à ce que vous
dites nulle part la preuve de son
efficacité contre le virus
d'autant qu'il ne faut pas être grand
clerc pour voir que les concentrations
de population qu'il produit dans les
transports comme les magasins constitue
au contraire un risque supplémentaire
comme l'ont constaté plusieurs études au
fond vous ne compter que sur le vaccin
pour sortir le pays d'affaires c'est
risqué
tout d'abord parce que silva sein est
absolument indispensable pour freiner la
maladie ou au moins atténuer les effets
nul aujourd'hui ne peut affirmer son
efficacité réelle et surtout prolongé
dans le temps contre sa transmission
question vaccin là aussi il faut faire
avec vous dans votre beau volte face qui
ne nous rassure pas je parle de la
question essentielle de la licence libre
que concrètement la france a refusé en
février dernier à l'om c'est devant la
demande de l'inde l'afrique du sud pour
finalement tout on pu entendre le chef
de l'état au sommet de porto dire que
c'est lui qui avait précédé joe biden
tout en expliquant ce n'était pas la
priorité du moment la seule nouveauté de
ce texte son coeur c'est donc le pass
sanitaires vous avez commencé par dire
qu'il ne saurait utiliser qu'aux
frontières histoire sûrement nous
rassurer
et vous proposer maintenant la dernière
minute d'étendre l'utilisation se passe
d'entrée à certains rassemblements
exactement ce que nous craignons c'est
un amendement déjà absurde car pourquoi
viser les foires où les rassemblements
aux loisirs et pas les autres
comme les lieux de travail ou de culte
mais surtout avec cet amendement c'est
le type de société que vous proposez qui
nous inquiète car nous savons bien nous
le voyons encore avec le couvre-feu
qu'une fois un principe admis vous en
élargissent et les domaines
d'application et durer non nous ne
sommes pas d'accord pour que les
français soient contrôlés surveillés
discriminés en fonction d'un état de
santé présumés vous dites que jamais le
pass sanitaire ne sera exigée dans les
activités quotidiennes
mais comment pouvez vous l'affirmer une
fois qu'il sera mis en place
comment y goûterez éviterez vous qui a
restaurateurs par exemple ne l'exigent à
l'entrée de son restaurant pour
satisfaire telle ou telle clientèle
je terminerai sur votre volonté de
vouloir imposer à votre aise à des
territoires des restrictions en fonction
du taux de contamination ce serait une
double peine car je vois bien par
exemple dans mon département de
seine-saint-denis que lorsque la
situation épidémique est plus grave
qu'ailleurs c'est du fait justement des
inégalités subies en offre de soins et
du fait de situations sociales
difficiles comme pour cette pensée
département comme pour tout le monde
d'ailleurs ce ne sont pas des punitions
territorialisée qu'il faut mais des
solutions appropriées
est ce que je constate au fond c'est que
votre stratégie consiste plus à
construire une société où on vit avec le
virus
plutôt que de se battre pour éradiquer
le virus pourtant il ya des alternatives
nous en avons proposé d'autres en ont
proposé vous pourriez organiser une
société enroulement le temps de la
pandémie
vous pourriez offrir de vraies
conditions matérielles permettant un
isolement des personnes contaminées
vous pourriez mettre en place un grand
plan d'urgence pour les hôpitaux
permettant la création de lits et
l'embauché de personnel vous pourriez
équiper les écoles et lieux d'activités
fermé amplificateur d'air et en capteur
de co2 vous pourriez développer
massivement les autotests mais rien de
tout cela dans votre loiriens tout cela
dit sera non plus puisque les
amendements que nous proposions sont
jugées recevables qui le proposaient
vous comprendrez donc chers collègues
que nous voterons contre cette voie de
gestion de la propagation de la crise
sanitaire et des restrictions inutiles
de liberté
merci la parole est à monsieur stéphane
peu pour le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues nous revoilà donc conduit à
prolonger une fois de plus l'état
d'urgence sanitaire car même si le
projet de loi prétend en organisait la
sortie c'est en réalité la poursuite
d'un fonctionnement dérogatoire à celui
de nos institutions dont il est question
aujourd'hui
certes la crise sanitaire est grave et
est loin d'être derrière nous et à
chaque fois que les députés communistes
ont eu l'occasion de le faire nous avons
souligné que le gouvernement de la
france en ces temps que le gouvernement
de la france par dont hans et en
particulier tout sauf aisé et que nous
n'entendons pas donner des leçons à tout
propos ou adopter un ton péremptoire
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons que
regretter la méthode finalement adoptée
par le président de la république l
exécutif l'elysée confiné avec une
poignée d'experts a choisi de décider de
tout tout seul sans s'appuyer sur le
parlement sans prendre en compte ce
qu'exprimaient les élus de tous les
territoires et de toute sensibilité sans
prendre en compte le retour d'expérience
sans solliciter solliciter leurs
propositions sans écouter les corps
intermédiaires les syndicats les
organisations professionnelles
au delà de l'agacement général que
suscite ce mode de fonctionnement
c'est bien la question de l'efficacité
qui est posée non la concentration des
pouvoirs n'est pas synonyme déficience
les mesures efficaces sont celles qui
sont éclairés légitime et donc consenti
au coeur d'un processus s'agissant c'est
bien le parlement que nous aurons que
nous aurions dû retrouver
il aurait été une aide précieuse pour
piloter cette crise corriger les erreurs
proposer et discuter des scénarios
alternatifs fondée sur les risques
identifiés sur le terrain dans nos
quartiers dans nos villages ou dans nos
entreprises
nous avions déjà alerté sur cette pente
tout à fait dangereuse et on ne peut
remarquer et s'inquiétait alors que
lorsque le pays se trouvent désormais
confrontés à une crise majeure ou ne
juger nos institutions à temps a relevé
le défi depuis 2015
nous avons été plus souvent soumis à
l'état d'urgence qu'à un fonctionnement
normal de nos institutions
c'est une question qui nous est posée
lorsque la confiance est si faible dans
la vie démocratique de
nos institutions que nous faisons le
choix de les contourner dès que le vent
se lève alors que les défis pourraient
se multiplier défi climatique des
guerres des crises économiques graves
un tel fonctionnement n'est pas
raisonnable oui chers collègues nous
nous sommes accoutumés à ce régime
dérogatoire et cette accoutumance et
dangereuse elle contribue à abîmer le
lien de confiance réciproque entre les
élus de la nation est les citoyennes et
les citoyens et renforcer également le
crédit au discours des partisans d'un
pouvoir fort et autoritaire
ainsi vous nous demandez de vous laisser
mettre en oeuvre quand vous le jugerez
utile le principe d'un pacs d'impasse
vaccinale nous aurions pu en a accepté
le principe d'une telle disposition mais
pas le blanc seing que vous nous
demandez cette proposition de loi qui
comporte pas ailleurs par ailleurs
plusieurs sujets d'inquiétudes sur
lesquels nous porterons des propositions
d'amendements je pense à l'abonnement du
fichier de santé avec des données qui ne
sont pas à nos mises et dont la sécurité
des conditions de recueil de stockage et
de traitement n'est pas garanti je
remarque encore et toujours
l'impensé sociale qui vous caractérise
avec par exemple des mesures qui vont
contraintes des salariés déjà durement
éprouvée à ne pouvoir profiter de leurs
congés que lorsque leur employeur le
voudra bien je pense également à la
trêve hivernale que vous refusez de
prolonger alors que pour nombre de
familles les difficultés ne se dissipe
pas bien au contraire
mes chers collègues pour l'ensemble de
ces motifs à la fois de principe mais
également dans les dispositions qu'il
comporte
vous ne serez pas surpris que nous
soyons amenés à rejeter ce texte
merci la parole était madame emmanuelle
ménard non inscrits
oh
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chars
collègues tenir encore quatre à six
semaines
le 1er mars dernier emmanuel macron
exhorté les français à serrer les dents
pour une nouvelle poignée de semaines et
laisser ainsi entrevoir la sortie du
tunnel on semaines plus tard le
gouvernement joue les prolongations avec
un nouveau texte qui pour la seconde
fois en un an et censé nous préparer à
une sortie de crise sanitaire
une sensation de déjà vu qui se voudrait
cette fois ci plus optimistes puisque
nous avons désormais dans notre jeu la
carte des vaccins mais bon comme
toujours depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire nos élans de liberté sont
rapidement tempéré par des discours qui
se veulent mesurer mais qui in fine est
inquiète car vous avez décidé de garder
la main sur les libertés individuelles
des français jusqu'au 31 octobre
rien que ça nous aurions pourtant pu
choisir une autre date comme certains
d'entre nous voulons proposer en
commission pas pour le plaisir pas non
plus pour nier la gravité de la
situation mais pour que le parlement
puisse jouer son rôle de contre-pouvoir
tout simplement
mais de cela vous ne voulez pas sans
refaire la sempiternelle recension de
tous vos loupes et des masques aux tests
en passant par les autotests tous les
vaccins
il faut bien avouer que le capital
confiance de votre gouvernement envers
les français est sérieusement entamée et
l'évincement systématique du parlement
ne plaide pas en votre faveur
un exemple qui me tient à coeur et pour
lequel malgré mes courriers mais
interpellation je n'ai jamais obtenu de
réponse
les vaccins et les centres de
vaccination après avoir demandé aux
communes d'être les relais légitime de
votre campagne vaccinale
après avoir promis votre soutien
indéfectible nous voilà un trimestre
plus tard avec des promesses qui
s'envole et d ardoise salée à béziers
nous sommes en capacité de vacciner sept
à dix mille personnes par semaine
rien que pour le premier trimestre de
son fonctionnement la ville de béziers a
déjà dépensé 5 195 milles euros
une coquette somme surtout quand on sait
que le gouvernement s'est engagé à en
rembourser 50 mille euros par trimestre
et que déjà cpam et ars se renvoient la
balle pour ne pas payer l'addition
avouer que nous sommes loin du quoi
qu'il en coûte
scandée par emmanuel
kron il y encore peu à slogan de plus
une réalité de moins mais je le concède
je m'éloigne du sujet qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui je ne poserai pas
contrairement à notre rapporteur santé
et libertés car liberté et sécurité
sanitaire sont les deux jambes d'une
véritable sortie de crise et pour en
sortir vous nous avez proposé monsieur
le ministre le pas de sanitaires impasse
qui à l'origine devait être réservé aux
déplacements vers ou depuis l'étranger
aujourd'hui il pourrait conditionner
l'accès à des grands rassemblements ou
lieu réunissant plus de 1000 personnes
durant tout l'été une simple jauge mais
qui semble déconnecté du bon sens par
manque évident de précision concernera
tel uniquement les lieux fermés ou
également les lieux ouverts sur
l'extérieur sera t-il fait une
différence selon la capacité d'accueil
du lieu est donc la densité de
population attendus
vous nous avez expliqué monsieur le
ministre que ce pass sanitaire ne
concernerait en rien les activités du
quotidien
même si faute il l'indiqué cette
précision n'est pas inscrite dans la loi
mais qu'est ce au juste qu'une activité
du quotidien le théâtre est il une
activité du quotidien et un match de
rugby où une messe ou une procession
autant de questions sans réponse autre
point litigieux de ce projet de loi les
données de santé contrairement à tous
les engagements pris
main sur le coeur par le gouvernement de
ne pas conserver ces données au delà du
31 décembre 2021
nous apprenons par ce texte que ces
données pourront finalement être
conservés 20 ans rien que ça et qu'au
lieu d'être anonymisées elles ne seront
que pseudo nomidia ce qui permettra le
cas échéant de retrouver l'identité des
personnes de quoi s'inquiéter
enfin dernier point d'achoppement leur
tour le recours systématique aux
ordonnances
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
s'est déjà 120 ordonnance qui ont été
prises dont très peu ont été ratifiés
par le parlement
j'ai d'ailleurs le plus grand mal à
obtenir le nombre exact de ces
ordonnances ratifiées
avouez que ce n'est pas très rassurant
alors mes chers collègues
si l'on peut se réjouir de voir que le
nombre de malades en réanimation est
passé sous la barre des 5000
gardons nous de continuer dans cette
direction car bientôt
ce pourrait être notre démocratie qu'il
faudrait mettre sous oxygène je vous
remercie
merci nous venons maintenant même
carrément lee qui s'exprime pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre messieurs les ministres je le
rapporteur sur le collègue je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure lors de de la motion de
rejet elle voulait peut-être ici revenir
ce de trois éléments qui me semble si
essentielle a rappelé l'objet disent
sûrs de nos ce nouveau texte c'est la
sorte ils organisaient la sortie de
l'état d'urgence je ferai trois
observations
la première concerne le temps le temps
passé à prolonger l'état d'urgence sans
améliorer les garanties données aux
français et à leurs représentants
parlement la deuxième porte sur un texte
qui vise à faire un texte qui met fin à
l'état d'urgence dans le flou et la 3ème
observation que je voulais formulées ici
je le rappelais les interrogations de
droit que nous formulons sur ce projet
que du temps perdu
mes chers collègues ce texte intervient
dans un contexte particulier avec trois
périodes confinement depuis 15 mois
nous aurions besoin d'avoir un débat
éclairé sur les enjeux de cette sortie
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais ne leur ont pas je les dis ici au
printemps 2020 rien ne s'opposait à la
mise en oeuvre de la loi de 1955 et de
l'article l 31-31 tiré à face à la
pandémie
cela n'a pas été le choix du
gouvernement est depuis l'assemblée dans
sa diversité a fait son travail pour
améliorer le régime de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire tous ici saussez banc les
proposition visait entre autres à ce que
les différents régimes d'urgence dispose
de garanties comparables avec une
information et une saisine constante du
parlement ou encore un avis du conseil
constitutionnel en s'inspirant de
l'article 16 de la constitution que soit
consolidée l'organisation des travaux du
parlement et que soit renforcé les
prérogatives des parlementaires et des
organes du parlement
en temps de crise que soit fixée une
durée de prorogation maximale en l'état
d'urgence sanitaire que soit organisé un
débat parlementaire à chaque rupture
constatée dans la connaissance
scientifique
le gouvernement n'a pas pris en compte
aucune n'a pris aucune de ces
propositions qui auraient pu faire en
tout cas consensus le temps passé à n'a
pas été mis en contribution pour mieux
prévoir discuter et contrôler et parle à
assurer la confiance des françaises de
français je le regrette le flou
entretenu un flou entretenu et ce
nouveau texte prévoit que du 2 juin au
31 octobre inclus c'est à dire pendant
cinq mois le premier ministre aura la
compétence de prendre des mesures
je suis par décret par l'intérêt de la
santé publique et aux seules fins de
lutter contre la prorogations
propagation par l'épidémie il va pouvoir
réglementer ou interdire dans certaines
parties du territoires dans lesquels est
constaté une circulation active du virus
la circulation des personnes des
véhicules se réserve déplacements
strictement indispensables aux besoins
familiaux professionnels de santé et
pour argue le mandé l'accès de locaux
ouverts au public il pourra aussi
réglementer les rassemblements de
personnes les réunions et les activités
sur la voie publique et dans les lieux
ouverts au public pour répondre à ces
dégradations localiser de la situation
sanitaire le texte précise que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire pourrait toutefois
être déclarés jusqu'au 31 octobre dans
une ou plusieurs circonscriptions
territoriales déterminée pour un délai
porté à 2 mois ce qui va de de l'au delà
de ce qui existe aujourd'hui je résumais
tout à l'heure la philosophie de ce
texte qui organise surtout avec autour
d'une sortie en état avec réaffirmation
d'une délégation permanente au profit de
l'exécutif a limité les les libertés
publiques et individuelles et la
possibilité de déléguer ce pouvoir aux
préfets dans le cadre d'une gestion
territorialisée cela était déjà la
critique et effet une critique faite
depuis juin 2020 et en l'état certaines
restrictions aux libertés fondamentales
pourrait être maintenu plusieurs mois
sans aucune intervention de notre
semblait ma troisième observations qui
portent plus sur l'absence des garanties
denain
puisque l'article 20 prévoit une
réhabilitation donné au gouvernement
pour réglementer la circulation des
personnes ou l'ouverture de certains
établissements il lui permet d'aller
jusqu'à une interdiction dans le même
ordre d'idées le passé ni terre qui a
été évoquée projet gouvernemental de
dernière minute déposées par un
amendement va pour la première fois
utilisé des données personnelles ça a
été évoqué à plusieurs reprises par nos
collègues alors nos propositions
d'amendements que nous nous souhaitons
défendre ici une nouvelle fois ces deux
à compenser les insuffisances de ce
projet qui relègue les représentants de
la nation que nous sommes qui restent
floues et qui comporte des risques pour
les libertés individuelles et publiques
sans s'assurer à ce stade que tout a été
bien pensé alors que pour terminer mes
chers collègues effectivement pour ces
raisons nous ne voterons pas ce texte
car ne souhaitait exercer les
responsabilités que la constitution nous
donne économique concitoyens trop
souvent nous reproche de ne pas exercer
avec vigilance et greg s'est mise mais
c'est un porteur donc nous en venons
donc j'appelle maintenant dans le texte
de la commission les articles du projet
de loi sur l'article le premier mail m
bonnaire la parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
messieurs les ministres alors en effet
depuis plus d'un an maintenant le
gouvernement navigue à vue
pas de visibilité aucune pour les
français sur les traitements par exemple
au surtout sur la réalité et les
motivations de l'absence d'accès aux
soins pour les français pas de
visibilité sur l'efficacité des vaccins
ni la transparence aujourd'hui sur
l'expérimentation en fait qui est en
cours sur l'ensemble des vaccins choisi
est autorisé en france
malgré notamment toutes les mises en
demeure que j'ai pu faire vis-à-vis du
ministre de la santé et vis-à-vis aussi
de l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament
pas de visibilité non plus pour des pans
entiers de l'économie des filières
entières qui n'ont plus d'avenir
aujourd'hui et j'en profite pour vous
passer les remerciements des des
stations de ski qui sont tout à fait
satisfait de la réouverture une fois de
plus ridicule
une fois de plus l'incohérence
l'ouverture des parcs d'attraction mais
pour les français
bien sûr sans pouvoir accéder aux dites
attractions mais en fait au fond laisse
que le gouvernement a jamais voulu le
bien des français depuis plus d'un an 6
tel avait été le cas au regard des
sommes colossales qui ont été dépensés
peut-être qu'il aurait renforcé les lie
peut-être qu'il aurait renforcé l'accès
aux soins
par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que ce
gouvernement sans les parlementaires
devient spécialiste des restrictions
spécialiste des privations spécialiste
des punitions et on aurait pu se laisser
séduire par le titre de ce projet de loi
mais je crains manifestement qu'une fois
de plus nous soyons déçus puisque la
réactivation possibles de cet état
d'urgence sanitaire est réel et sera
réel jusqu'au 31 12 alors faites
confiance s'il vous plaît messieurs les
ministres aux parlementaires pour
réinstaurer le débat est réinstauré
enfin la démocratie dans notre pays
je vous remercie merci oui merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres sur le reporter la démocratie
ça commence déjà par le respect il ya
près de deux heures que nous sommes
réunis dans cet hémicycle qu'une motion
de rejet a été certes rejetée mais elle
a été débattu une dizaine d'orateurs se
sont succédés responsable de groupe et y
compris un président de groupe
nous avons deux ministres présents
mais pas un mot pas une intervention ni
du ministre de la santé qui a mieux à
faire et qui pianote sur son portable
mais il a sans doute des choses plus
urgentes non mais j'en ai ras le bol
j'en ai ras-le-bol c'est un mépris
c'est un mépris depuis le seul ici on
est le regard de créer une réponse du
ministre des ministres puisqu'on en a
deux pour le prix d'un aujourd'hui c'est
très bien mais si on allait muet du
sérail
à quoi ça sert d'avoir des ministres
présents le respect la démocratie c'est
au moins d'essayer de répondre aux
questions légitimes
je rappelle que nous avons cinq
questions le groupe socialiste en a cinq
mais le modem en a trois eh bien dansez
5 et 3 il y en a trois qui sont communes
ça devrait vous interpeller même dans la
majorité il y à des questions qui se
posent
oui sur les grands rassemblements oui
sur les données personnelles
oui sur le couvre feu oui sur le pad
sanitaires et il n'y a aucune réponse
des ministres on arrive à l'article 1er
on les a pas entendus en dehors du
ministre de la santé qui présente le
texte vous trouvez que c'est normal
c'est ça le respect du parlement
ça montre bien monsieur keitel ça montre
bien la tartufferie ici à cette heure je
vous le dis
nous en venons à toujours dans les
orateurs systématique de monsieur
brindeau merci monsieur le merci
monsieur le président il est vrai
monsieur le ministre qui a un certain
nombre de questions qui ont été posées
par des parlementaires moi même lors de
la discussion générale vous étiez sortie
mais donc je vous repose la question et
j'aimerais vraiment avoir une réponse
parce que c'est un vrai sujet sur lequel
nos concitoyens ont besoin de lisibilité
encore une fois sur cette question du
pass sanitaire la question elle est la
suivante
aujourd'hui on nous dit si vous
évidemment présenté un certificat de
vaccination
pas de problème si vous présentez un
test pcr négatif de - quarante-huit
heures pas de problème et éventuellement
si vous présenter un certificat de
contamination en fête et de guérison
donc de présence d'anticorps à la copie
de 19 possible ou pas possible vous nous
disiez lors des débats en commission que
vous attendiez un certain nombre de
confirmations notamment des autorités
sanitaires qu'elle soit européenne ou
française
où en est-on de cette question est-ce
que ce test ou ce certificat de
contamination est donc de présence
d'anticorps qu'ovide 19 pourra
effectivement être intégré à l'une des
alternatives possibles dans le cadre du
pass sanitaires sur sur cette question
là comme d'ailleurs sur beaucoup
d'autres et ce ne sont pas des questions
polémiques pour le coup ce sont de
vraies questions qui si elles n'ont pas
de réponses dans notre débat d'abord
nous amèneront à considérer qu
effectivement vous fait peu de cas du
débat parlementaire dont pourtant vous
dit qu'il a été à maintes fois sollicité
mais en réalité on peut être sollicité
et si on parle dans le vide et qu'on
n'est jamais entendue et qu'on a jamais
de réponses à nos questions et bien
effectivement ça atteste l'idée que
peut-être nous ne servons à rien mais en
tout cas ce sont des questions dont nos
concitoyens ont absolument besoin
d'avoir des réponses
merci je ne vois pas d'autres orateurs
inscrits sur l'article nous venons donc
aux questions aux amendements et un plat
que les amendements de suppression mais
l'abonné a la parole pour le 12
merci monsieur le président c'est en
effet un amendement qui sera repris
après également par par le groupe
liberté territoire et monsieur molac ans
défendra un suivant il consiste à
supprimer a proposé la suppression de
cet article
en effet l'état d'urgence sanitaire ne
devait au départ ne durer que deux mois
et ce régime d'exception les français en
ont plus qu'assez il ne fait que durer
encore et encore et on a beau faire
croire aux français qu'il s'agit d'une
gestion de sortie de crise il n'est
absolument pas question de ça dans ce
projet de loi puisque on parle de
couvre-feu 21h à quel moment les
parlementaires ont pu ont pu discuter de
cette de cet horaire de couvre-feu sur
quelle base sur quelles bases
scientifiques continus temps de penser
que le confinement pour être efficace
c'est que le couvre-feu à 21h aurait la
moindre la moindre efficacité également
l'introduction du pass sanitaires il y
avait eu une enquête menée par le cae
auprès de 110 mille citoyens qui se sont
exprimés à hauteur de 72% contre se
passe sanitaires il convient enfin de
pouvoir écouter les citoyens français et
une inquiétude également sur ses données
sur la collecte des données c'est au
delà de l'article 1
on y reviendra mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on ne peut que constater
malheureusement que des personnes qui
simplement prennent rendez-vous sur des
plateformes de type d'octo libre se voit
en effet pour chasser sollicité en
permanence pour pour aller vers d'autres
consultations vers éventuellement la
vaccination donc cela suffit il faut
protéger les français sous quelque forme
que ce soit et donc je propose là la
suppression de cet article je vous
remercie également pour un amendement de
suppression ménard merci monsieur le
président oui nous nous retrouvons
régulièrement maintenant pour proroger
l'état d'urgence sanitaire mais chaque
fois vous écarter le parlement de son
contrôle alors s'il est vrai que les
mesures que vous nous proposez
aujourd'hui sont de moindre portée
qu'auparavant et qu'elles ont aussi
l'avantagé d'être territorialisée
certaines décisions ont été vraiment
très dur à accepter pour les français et
il est plus que temps de leur donner un
peu de clarté ou de lisibilité
cet article 1er du projet de loi propose
un régime de 2 me sortit de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui commencera donc
par une étape d'allègement mais
immédiatement assorti du maintien d'un
couvre-feu pendant un mois alors qu'il
est censé définir ce régime de sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire l'article 1er
continue malheureusement de restreinte
grandement de liberté pour cinq mois
supplémentaire est exactement comme le
projet de loi qui nous avait été soumis
l'an dernier il reprend les restrictions
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et il en
ajoute même de nouvelles alors il n'est
pas acceptable que le gouvernement
dispose pour une durée aussi longue du
pouvoir de suspendre nos libertés du
jour au lendemain nous avons fait nous
sommes plusieurs parlementaires fait des
propositions pour diminuer cette cette
durée parce que la démocratie ne peut
pas être mise entre parenthèses pour 5
mois de plus on ne peut pas rester dans
un entre-deux non plus soit la situation
sanitaire permet de sortir l'état
d'urgence et il faut le faire soit ne le
permet pas et à ce moment là il faut le
maintenir
et je le répète il est essentiel de
trouver enfin un équilibre
institutionnel entre l'exécutif qui doit
c'est vrai pouvoir gérer les choses au
plus vite et le parlement qui se trouve
de fait des saisies d'une partie de son
pouvoir et comme nous n'avons pas de
réponses à toutes ces questions
on est pas de réponse satisfaisante il
convient donc de supprimer cet article
afin notamment de redonner ses pouvoirs
au parlement je vous remercie monsieur
merci le 64e en en plus pression sur
windows la parole oui merci monsieur le
président nous nous défendons un
amendement de suppression pour marquer
notre désaccord fondamental avec la
méthode qui est celle du gouvernement
depuis un an et qui est systématiquement
de demander entre guillemets les pleins
pouvoirs au parlement dans tous les
domaines de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire à la fois effectivement pour
prendre des mesures qui protègent la
santé de nos concitoyens et puis aussi
pour accompagner les conséquences de
cette crise sanitaire sur la vie
économique et sociale alors même que
l'ensemble de ces mesures mérite un
débat indispensable pour pouvoir que nos
concitoyens y adhèrent et d'études
d'opinion en études d'opinion constante
nos concitoyens ne vous font pas
confiance pour gérer cette crise
sanitaire et ses conséquences et ça ça
appelle normalement de votre part à une
forme de responsabilité qui devrait
consister à se dire il faut obtenir non
pas un consensus mou comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le ministre dans votre
intervention liminaire d'ailleurs dans
votre seule intervention pour le moment
sur ce texte
mais un vrai débat parce que c'est
l'essence encore une fois de la
démocratie et c'est ce qui fait que nos
concitoyens pourront reprendre confiance
non pas seulement reprendre confiance
sur l'issue de la crise sanitaire
mais reprendre confiance sur la façon
dont nous avons collectivement organiser
des débats pour que confrontation des
idées
accords & désaccords ça ça fait partie
de la vie politique
c'est extrêmement les victimes eh bien
nous trouvions des solutions autrement
que pour avoir donné entre guillemets
les clés du camion à l'exécutif et que
un conseil de défense
un président de la république décide
seul de tous
et le fasse appliquer ensuite par son
exécutif
et quand il faut bien évidemment de
temps en temps venir devant le parlement
et bien faire en sorte que sa majorité
qui ne vois pas d'ailleurs la
responsabilité qui est la sienne dans ce
décalage entre nos concitoyens et
quelque part notre vie politique et bien
docilement puisse adopter les mesures de
reconduction in fine et de l'état
d'urgence permanent merci monsieur
gosselin pour le sang merci monsieur le
président oui nous sommes avec cet
article 1er d'ores et déjà dans le coeur
du sujet nous pouvons nous réjouir
d'avoir des perspectives de sortie de
l'état d'urgence ça veut dire que malgré
la situation
les choses sont quand même en train de
s'améliorer et nul ne le conteste et
encore une fois chacun peut s'en réduit
s'en réjouir surtout tous les rangs mais
attention cette sortie qui nous est
proposé aujourd'hui en réalité est tout
sauf une vraie sortie
encore une fois ça l'apparence de la
liberté l'apparence du changement mais
le changement c'était le 10 mai 81 le 10
mai 2021 c'est plutôt la continuité la
continuité parce qu'en réalité on se
retrouve avec les sempiternelles mêmes
questions et sans réponse
du reste c'est la longueur du tunnel qui
nous mène jusqu'au 31 octobre 2021 et la
possibilité d'activer pratiquement tous
les leviers pour le gouvernement sans le
contrôle du gouvernement qu'il serait
trop compliqué de réunir dont les
collaborateurs sont fatigués enfin bref
il va falloir souffrir encore un peu ce
fichu parlement qui décidément radote et
vivement qu'on puisse voter ce texte et
qu'on y revienne pas c'est un peu ça
donc c'est un long tunnel ça finit par
agacer et surtout paraître
incompréhensible parce que ça nuit
évidemment gravement à l'acceptation à
l'acceptabilité de la parole publique
c'est un couvre-feu aussi qui va pouvoir
s'ouvrir au mois de juin malgré la fin
de ce confinement
c'est aussi le pass sanitaires
qui est en jeu par amendement
gouvernemental est encore une fois ni le
conseil d'état ni la cnil n'ont pu se
prononcer dessus
bref un certain nombre de questions qui
mériteraient des réponses
on peut ne pas partager les réponses
mais on pourrait au moins avoir des
réponses et bien rien donc ce n'est pas
très engageant
ce n'est pas un débat qu'on peut
qualifier de seraing et il est à peine
démocratique parce que quand on est dans
un jeu d'apparence et ce soir j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'être dans un jeu
d'apparence où chacun attend et puis on
va jouer la montre pour essayer de voter
ou plus vite ça ne peut pas nous
satisfaire donc amendement de
suppression
avec cette proposition monsieur que
craignent la parole pour le 5 mm2 merci
oui à un amendement de suppression aussi
parce que ce qu'on nous propose c'est
pas rien quand même
d'accord vous l'avez dit vous-même c'est
un copier coller de l'article 1er la loi
du 9 juillet 2020 qui organise la sortie
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
il ya presque un an déjà je rappelle
qu'on nous l'a déjà fait c'était il ya
presque un an
or dans cette danse était dans sept
projets de loi on parle de restrictions
libertés de circulation de réunion de
manifestation des amendes qui vont avec
et qui ne sont pas pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens d amende symbolique loin de
là on parle d'interdire la circulation
de personnes interdire les déplacements
de c1 sont en réalité depuis le rendu du
conseil consul du 9 juillet la seule
chose dont on est sûr c'est que ça ne
permet pas un confinement généralisée
mais par ailleurs ça permet de réduire
considérablement la liberté donc
effectivement stature pour nous faire
passer la pilule cioni je vous ai
entendu qu à l'heure vous nous at il dit
rassurez vous c'est pour la sortie bien
mais la comprenez que on ait des doutes
le 1er mars dernier fort du couvre feu
donc vous nous dites que c'est tellement
scientifiques qu'on ne peut le contester
le présent la république avait expliqué
qu'on en avait pour quatre semaines
quatre semaines après non seulement le
couvre-feu était maintenu mais ont fermé
les écoles et on interdisait de se
déplacer entre les régions vous
comprendrez donc vos estimations ne nous
rassure pas sûr j'allais dire l'
équilibre à trouver entre la dangerosité
au niveau des libertés
de telles mesures et puis son impact
sanitaire
et c'est bien le tout
qui est ici moi je crois que il serait
temps au contraire d'organiser un débat
qui permet de passer d'un régime
d'exception et de coercition à une
organisation une planification de la
société en sachant qu'il faut essayer
d'éradiquer le virus mais que ça va
prendre effectivement des mois et des
mois les fautes de ce débat je pense
qu'on se retrouve ici autour dans
l'assemblée entre des personnes qui
constatent que l'épidémie continue
malgré ce qui est dit et d'un autre côté
qu on nous restreint les libertés de
manière de plus en plus insupportable
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens
[Musique]
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur leurs abords d'un monsieur le
ministre charcot legs le dispositif de
sortie d' état d'urgence sanitaire reste
un état d'exception qui déroge au droit
commun et qui maintient les mesures de
police sanitaire restrictives de liberté
ce dispositif identique à celui instauré
par la loi du 9 juillet 2020 est un
entre deux qui avait déjà montré ses
limites à l'été dernier soit la
situation sanitaire mérite de rester en
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
en utilisant l'ensemble des outils
permis en cet état soit la situation
sanitaire est suffisamment sûre pour
sortir enfin de son état d'exception
ainsi vous vous arrogez la possibilité
de réduire ou suspendre plusieurs
libertés fondamentales du jour au
lendemain sans y associer le parlement
nous proposons donc à travers cet
amendement de supprimer cet article qui
a de surcroît une durée d'application
extrêmement longue jusqu'au 31 octobre
merci le 180ème caillou défendu le 182e
au lac
oui il ya bien le régime d'état
d'urgence et c est raté
si on continue comme ça ça fera tout
simplement plus d'un an et demi que nous
serons dans un état d'urgence qui ne dit
pas son nom pour celui que nous allons
sans doute voter tout à l'heure mais
pour moi il ya une question de fond qui
a été souligné par un certain nombre de
nos comptes de des orateurs ici et
finalement c'est bien là la question de
la démocratie et de la séparation des
pouvoirs
soit en croit la démocratie et dans ces
cas-là le parlement doit être associée
soit on et bonapartiste et on pense que
l'état l'administration font toujours
mieux que les élus ce que je ne crois
absolument pas et je n'ai pas été élu
par le peuple pour me dessaisir de
pouvoir qu'il m'a donné donc il est hors
de question
évidemment que je vote cet état
d'urgence merci monsieur peu le 193
oui merci monsieur président très
brièvement également pour présenter
également un amendement de suppression
on nous présente cette proposition de
loi comme une proposition de sortie mais
finalement c'est surtout une proposition
de perpétuation d'un régime dérogatoire
au moins jusqu'au 31 d'un 31 octobre et
les 10 je le répète je pense que c'est
pas sain pour nos institutions c'est
dangereux pour la démocratie je ne
reviens pas sur ce que je disais tout à
l'heure et en plus c'est inefficace pour
avoir des décisions prises avec le plus
des changes possible pour qu'elle soit
le mieux consenti possible par notre
peuple donc dangereux inefficace tout ça
sont des raisons qui nous semble assez
suffisante pour justifier cet amendement
de suppression
[Musique]
merci
le 228 et défendu défendu le 230 n'est
pas défendu sur cette série
d'amendements de suppression monsieur
rapporteur qui a des avis de la
commission
merci monsieur le président ces
amendements donc pourrait faire tomber
l'ensemble des mesures prises pour faire
face à la lutte contre ce virus dès le 2
juin
je vous assure que le 2 juin ce virus
sera toujours présent pour certains les
outils du droit commun pourrait suffire
moi je ne crois pas pour d'autres ce
serait simple ce serait la prolongation
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
nous avons choisi plutôt d'assumer la
sortie avec la fin du confinement au 1er
juin et la fin du couvre-feu au 30 juin
donc c'est un avis défavorable contre
pour ces amendements qui avec leur
adoption serait catastrophique pour
notre pays et pour la protection de la
santé des français et vash ministre vous
avez la parole ces amendements de
suppression un avis évidemment
défavorable monsieur le président encore
une fois les parlementaires sont invités
à se prononcer pour savoir de quelle
doute quels outils notre franc de notre
pays la france peut se doter pour
protéger les français ses habitants et
lutter avec efficacité contre l'épidémie
une fois encore nous avons un débat avec
une majorité présente solide qui a
toujours suivi voter courageusement
faveur des mesures qui protègent et une
fois encore pour différentes raisons et
que je ne conteste pas c'est pas mon
rôle
l'ensemble de l'opposition réunis qui si
des amendements visant à ne pas nous
permettre de prendre en place de mettre
en place ces mesures de protection pour
les français encore une fois certains
considérant que le poids du parlement
n'est pas suffisant monsieur gosselin il
ya autant ministre aux banques député lr
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
il ya autant de ministres au banc que
deux députés maires présents dans cet
hémicycle monsieur gosselaar donc les
leçons de démocratie vous je voulais je
vous les laisse moi je suis toujours
présent monsieur le député j'ai toujours
été présent chaque minute des débats il
ya d'autres parlementaires qui considère
que les mesures ne sont pas
proportionnés ou disproportionnées ou
non efficace et bien écoutez je vous
renvoie encore une fois aux données
épidémiologiques à ce qui se passe en
france en allemagne en italie en espagne
en angleterre dans tous les pays qui ont
su prendre des mesures courageuses pour
protéger les populations
et n'allez pas croire une seconde que si
nous ne sommes pas à 70 mille cas jour
aujourd'hui mais à 18000 les mesures qui
ont été votées par la majorité n'y sont
pour rien c'est tout l'inversé les
mesures ont été protégés crise et c'est
ce qui nous permet aujourd'hui
d'entrevoir le bout du tunnel
donc évidemment monsieur le président un
avis défavorable parce que si le
parlement devait voter aujourd'hui la
fin de toute disposition nous permettant
dans les semaines qui viennent
alors que l'épidémie n'est pas terminée
alors qu'il ya encore cinq mille malades
dans les rayons française de prendre des
mesures de freinage pour éviter la
diffusion du virus
je ne veux pas parler à la place des
français mais je pense que ils ne
comprendraient pas merci merci monsieur
gosselin la parole monsieur que crel un
fluide
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous pouvez attaquer si
c'est bon vous chante les nerfs leur
présence etc
mais je rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de dlr
ici premier point et quand bien même
nous ne serions qu'un seul présent
d'autres le sont largement et les
interrogations sont venues aussi bien
des bandes et l'opposition que de la
majorité on partage au moins trois
questions essentielles et répondre à ces
questions ce n'est pas s'abaisser
sauf à considérer que le temps passé au
parlement et du temps perdu et qu'on a
mieux à faire je veux bien l'entendre
mais souffrait que sous la vème
république de temps en temps pas très
souvent je le reconnais on réunit
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat pour
essayer de légiférer parfois de contrôle
et parfois de proposer mais je comprends
que ça soit un peu compliqué à souffrir
ceci étant nous ne sommes pas dans une
position binaire évidemment vous
cherchez à cornet risée vous cherchez à
faire deux clans un clan qui serait
celui de la majorité qui forcément
serait vertueux et le clan des
oppositions qui veulent la mort de nos
concitoyens la propagation de la maladie
et cetera
ce n'est pas évidemment binaire ainsi
nous ne sommes pas en accord avec vous
sur cette sortie tel que vous nous l'a
proposé
ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous
refusons un certain nombre de mesures au
gouvernement
ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous
empêcherons le gouvernement de
travailler seulement nous voulons des
explications sur le pass and i ter sur
les délais sur les données de santé et
sur d'autres éléments
ça ne me paraît pas une question
superflue il faut t'y répondre avant son
ensemble et ne n'évacuer pas d'un revers
de main presque paix dans les remarques
qui vous déplaisent
merci excuses à monsieur verrons mais
depuis un an chaque je vous écoute
c'est à peu près toujours les mêmes
arguments c'est à chaque fois que
l'opposition tente de dire qu' il serait
peut-être souhaitable de chercher
d'autres solutions
vous nous dites si on ne vote pas telle
qu'elle est la loi
eh bien les français seront face à
l'épidémie et vous prendrez vos
responsabilités à chaque fois il ya une
espèce de culpabilisation
alors j'ai un collègue qui veut parler
l'acca s'est inscrit à amender mes chers
collègues nous ne faisons qu amendé au
point même où la moitié nos deux
amendements que proposait cette fois ci
sont irrecevables
alors même qu'ils étaient au coeur du
sujet mais ça au débat je continue nous
avons c'est pas comme si en plus
encore une fois monsieur véran tout ce
que vous avez imaginé depuis un an était
à chaque fois sorti de succès vous savez
très bien et je peux même pas où jeter
la pierre éventuellement on peut estimer
donc on efface une épidémie dans
laquelle on se trompe
mais vous savez très bien que ce
qu'avait dit monsieur maquereau en
janvier ne sait pas ne sais pas n'a pas
été atteint l'idée ce pari avec le
couvre-feu de ne pas passer au dessus
des 20 mille cas par jour qui permettait
de ne pas fermer les écoles continuer à
produire et à faire en sorte que
l'économie fonctionne vous savez très
bien comme moi que ça n'a pas fonctionné
ce les mesures que vous avez pris le
variant le savait dès janvier j'ai été
avec monsieur véran justement à l' ol
agences régionales de santé où on nous
expliquait au moment même où vous étiez
quelques-uns déjà à penser qu'il fallait
revenir au confinement que le variant
arrivait tous les chiffres étaient
connus donc nous dit pas le variant
comme si t'es pas prêt vous avez mis en
place un certain nombre
non monsieur macron d'ailleurs admis en
place qui ne se sont pas révélés
efficaces
donc à partir de là souffrez que nous
vous proposions d'autres mesures que
nous contestions par exemple
effectivement la question du passé ni
terre est d'ailleurs j'observe je vous
ai entendu je vais grandir la majorité
vote ce que le gouvernement propose bon
ça on ça quelque part c'est j'allais
dire presque une règle chez vous mais
j'ai entendu dans les débats de la
commission certaines personnes de la
majorité poser des questions poser les
mêmes questions que l'opposition donc
manifestement il ya un débat et c'est
vrai que moi j'aimerais c'est la seule
chose dit vous nous donnez vous nous
donner à certains moments des réponses
sans même jugé nécessaire d'argumenter
vous nous dites le couvre-feu c'est
efficace sans même nous dire en quoi ils
efficaces
quelles sont les mesures les études sur
lesquelles vous appuyer de façon à ce
qu'on ait un débat intéressant c'est pas
une façon de débattre on y reviendra
malabo l'air à la parole merci monsieur
le président alors je vais citer les
mots du président de la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme
en temps de paix la république n'a
jamais connu une telle restriction de
liberté alors le gouvernement fait la
guerre à qui si ce n'est aux français
pourquoi autant de restrictions de
liberté toujours et encore quand on veut
lutter contre une épidémie on soigne
tout simplement et on ne m'en ferme pas
on ne confirme pas on ne prolonge pas où
on se donne pas les moyens de continuer
ce couvre feu donc lui il faut supprimer
cet article vous avez cité tout à
l'heure et je ne nie absolument pas la
situation sanitaire
c'est vrai qu'en absolument pas non
chers collègues je ne la nie absolument
pas absolument négoce valvulaire par
contre les chiffres en permanence qui
ont été et qui continuent à être mises
en avant sont simplement là pour
entretenir la peur chez les français
parlé de plus de 100000 morts oui mais
sans avoir remis du tout les compteurs à
zéro et c'est aussi négligé les cinq
cent mille autres décès en dehors de
l'aco vide
pourquoi ne parle t'on pas des six cent
mille morts qui ont qui existent
malheureusement depuis plus d'un an ont
fait cette fixation sur la queue vide
mais d'abord on aurait pu limiter très
clairement ce nombre de décès et
pourquoi monsieur le ministre ne changez
vous pas enfin de stratégie et ne
proposez vous pas en accompagnement de
la proposition des vaccins aussi
également l'accès à des traitements je
vous remercie
merci donc je vais mettre voit ces
amendements de suppression qui font
l'objet d'un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour l'adoption de ces amendements qui
est contre ils sont rejetés
nous venons au 59 la meynard pour une
discussion commune
merci mais ce président oui c'est tuer
un amendement qui propose de ramener de
raccourcir ce cette période de cinq mois
que vous nous proposez pour sortir de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est de
ramener la sortie au 14 juillet alors
pourquoi le 14 juillet et bien parce que
je me suis référé au commissaire
européen au marché intérieur monsieur
thierry breton qui nous expliquait il ya
quelques jours encore que grâce à la
hausse de livraison de vaccins l'europe
devrait atteindre une immunité
collective
le 14 juillet prochain il me semble donc
c'est une bonne date et que c'est un bon
terme pour pour fixer la fin de régime
de sortie de l'état d'urgence et en plus
c'est une date vous en conviendrez à une
date extrêmement symbolique
donc au lieu du 31 décembre 2021 on
pourrait fixer la sortie de l'état
d'urgence au 14 juillet afin d'obéir au
strict principe
au principe de stricte nécessité et de
proportionnalité l'application de ces
deux principes est d'autant plus
importante que cet article permet de
suspendre vous le savez un grand nombre
de libertés fondamentales et l'objectif
de cet amendement est donc simple
quitter le régime d'exception que nous
connaissons depuis un an et très
rapidement et permettre si les
circonstances l'exigent il exige que le
parlement puisse être saisi à nouveau au
mois de juillet je vous remercie
merci dans l'agriculture comme une
également le 213 qu'il ait des fourriers
défendu mes chers collègues défendu
toujours le dit ce n'est pas défendu le
souhait temple merci monsieur le
président c'est un amendement de repli
donc qui fixe la date cette fois-ci de
sortie au 31 juillet 2021 puisque vous
nous avez expliqué en commission
monsieur le ministre que vous aviez fixé
en fait la date du 31 octobre notamment
pour éviter l'écueil des vacances d'été
et d'éviter de devoir si la situation se
détériorait convoqué en urgence le
parlement durant l'été alors moi je vous
propose donc de fixer cette sortie de
l'état d'urgence au 31 juillet et pas
octobre puisque de toute façon à cette
date là le parlement le parlement sera
toujours siègera toujours en session
extraordinaire et donc sera parfaitement
capable de se réunir pour exercer ses
prérogatives
je l'avais déjà rappelé en commission je
l' ai redit en discussion générale
diminué et est restreinte 7 cette
période c'est pas pour se faire plaisir
c'est pas non plus pour nier
l'importance de la crise sanitaire parce
que personne ne peut la nier aujourd'hui
c'est simplement pour fixer une espèce
de clause de revoyure bien plus proche
pour permettre au parlement de d'exercer
ses prérogatives
et puis pour permettre un libre exercice
de la démocratie me semble que c'est pas
tout à fait c'est pas tout à fait un
conséquent et que pour les français
surtout en période d'élection électorale
ça peut paraître important je vous
remercie
merci monsieur malade pour le 183 qui
est identique
oui alors c'est le même en fait et qui
met la date du 31 juillet parce
qu'effectivement nous serons là au mois
de juillet et que donc on pourra
si nécessaire repousser cet état
d'urgence sanitaire qui le dit son nom
mais monsieur le ministre vous avez été
très caricatural parce que ce qu'on lui
reproche
ce n'est pas de prendre des décisions
c'est de prendre tout seul de façon
unilatérale et monsieur brecht par
exemple a posé une question sur
l'éradication
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a jamais eu de
débat dans cet hémicycle justement sur
les différentes façons de lutter contre
le virus
on ne l'a jamais eue donc je suis désolé
mais on ne peut pas accepter le fait
qu'il y ait un seul homme qui décide
aujourd'hui le conseil scientifique est
relativement je dirais critique sur la
sincérité nombre de mesures qui ont été
faites pour ma part je pense qu'un
certain nombre de choses ont été bien
faites mais pour autant je n'ai jamais
pu le dire ici puisque nous n'avons
jamais eu ce genre de discussions donc
c'est ça qui pose problème et c'est ça
qui pose problème dans une démocratie
merci d'abord dans une nouvelle série
d'amendements identiques d'un set de
discussion commune le centquatre
toujours une question de date
effectivement alors on peut avoir des
points de vue différents sur le mois de
juillet le mois d'août tout ça je
l'entends bien c'est le risque
lorsqu'il ya des changements de dates
c'est comme les effets de seuil c'est
toujours très compliqué à manier mais là
point d'accord et que nous ne souhaitons
pas un long tunnel longue et et sans
clause de revoyure ça ne fait jamais que
une dizaine de fois je crois qu'on le
rappelle dans les différents textes sur
l'état d'urgence
régulièrement on nous fait revenir mais
contraint et forcé ce que nous
souhaitons évidemment c'est qu'il ya une
clause de revoyure précise voter
d'un commun accord il nous semble que
celle du 31 août est une date qui
pourrait convenir pourquoi il n'est pas
question évidemment de laisser
l'épidémie
prospéré pendant les grandes vacances où
il ya des rassemblements familiaux
amicaux et il n'est pas question
monsieur le ministre de d'enlever le
moindre parcelle de compétence au
gouvernement mais le mois d'août le 31
août permet au mois de juillet de réunir
le parlement sans aucune difficulté avec
les oppositions récalcitrantes qu'il
faut souffrir mais elles seront là
rassurez-vous et la majorité qui sera là
aussi et donc le débat pourra avoir lieu
sans risque d'être mis en minorité mais
au moins à la lumière des derniers
chiffres à la lumière de ce qui se
serait passé
fin mai en juin et jusqu'à la mi juillet
en gros on a déjà pu le faire on sait
faire encore faut-il vouloir le faire et
ça c'est autre chose et on sent bien une
forme d'obstination
merci le 534 identique même caillou
défendu défendu
monsieur brun de 2,65
oui merci monsieur le président ce débat
sur les dates de sortie quelque part des
mesures transitoires est tout sauf un
débat cosmétiques parce que ils
conditionnent quelque part
l'acceptabilité à la fois du parlement
de considérer qu en se dessaisissant de
ses pouvoirs et ses prérogatives
essentielles y compris en matière de
libertés publiques il fait oeuvre utile
mais aussi de l'acceptabilité de nos
concitoyens parce que plus la date est
lointaine
plus vous installer dans l'état d'esprit
de nos concitoyens l'idée que peut-être
les mesures qui sont prises ne seront
pas ou ne sont pas aussi efficace qu'on
veut bien le dire que peut-être y
compris la vaccination massive n'est pas
la garantie que demain nous pourrons
effectivement
mettre fin à cette situation nous devons
vivre avec le virus est plutôt que de
pouvoir à un moment donné on éradique et
sa présence sur sur notre territoire
donc encore une fois ça n'est pas un
débat cosmétiques et par pitié ne nous
répondait pas ce qui a été répondu en
commission que finalement puisque il ya
des propositions qui vont du 14 juillet
jusqu'au 30 septembre c'est que sans
doute la date du 31 octobre est la bonne
essayons au moins d'avoir un débat un
peu construit sur ces questions et ne
pas caricaturer à dessein chaque fois
que des parlementaires font des
propositions qui ne sont pas les vôtres
tila autre série d'amendements
identiques commençant par le 45
mais avant de donner la parole à madame
caramanlis a informé l'assemblée que sur
cet amendement et sur ceux qui lui sont
identiques et la demande du groupe
socialiste et apparentés lire un scrutin
public
le scrutin est annoncée dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée nationale 24 ml à la
parole oui merci monsieur le président
dans le même esprit que les différents
collègues s'exprimaient jusqu'ici sur
les questions de délais c'est aussi cet
esprit effectivement de ramener la date
de raccourcir cette date là pourquoi
parce que effectivement les principales
mesures aujourd'hui qui sont proposés de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire que sur la
limitation par exemple de la circulation
des personnes et des contraintes
imposées selon la circulation des virus
comme ça a été évoqué et pose quand même
soulève beaucoup de questions à la fois
parce que ça paraît floue ce n'est pas
déterminée et aussi il faut rappeler que
ce référentiel n'est pas aujourd'hui
suffisamment précise et il n'existe pas
de limitation dans le temps de la mise
en oeuvre des mesures prévues à
l'article 1 et on peut même voir dans
certains territoires y compris l'île de
france par exemple de voir pendant cinq
mois
les mêmes mesures de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire sans que le parlement est plus
donnait son point de vue et intervenir
donc pour ces raisons là on nous
proposons une autre date
mais de manière plus symbolique aussi
nous souhaitons à travers ce vote de ce
que tu as un public
une manière soutenir l'ensemble de la
volonté exprimée par les différents
collègues sur tous les bancs la demande
est finalement gouvernement de limiter
cette cet état d'urgence et de le
ramener de manière plus courte
merci amendements identiques monsieur la
tombe
merci monsieur le président a
effectivement comme j'ai pu le dire dans
la discussion générale pour l'ensemble
du groupe démocrate au mouvement
démocrate et démocrate apparenté nous
souhaitons que la date soit avancée et
cela en cohérence avec les annonces qui
ont été faites par le président de la
république et par le gouvernement
lui-même
quand ils ont annoncé des dates et des
échéances notamment en indiquant que
tous les français adultes qui voudraient
pouvoir se faire vacciner aurait eu la
possibilité de le faire avant la fin de
l'été donc par cohérence on pourrait
avoir mis une date à la fin de l'été on
peut comprendre qu'à la ligne avec la
livraison des vaccins qui peuvent de
temps entre eux et erratique avec les
les vacances qui font qu'il ya des
déplacements de population on pourrait
se laisser un tout petit peu de marge
c'est pour ça que nous proposons 30
septembre mais aller jusqu'au 31 octobre
ça n'est pas aujourd'hui ce que nous
souhaitons nous souhaitons absolument le
30 septembre et cela en cohérence et
vous remarquerez monsieur le ministre
que l'ensemble des oppositions et notre
groupe parti de la majorité déposer un
moment pour dire qu'à date du 31 octobre
est trop lointaine et vous nous avez
demandé à plusieurs reprises et on l'a
déjà dit lors des discussions générales
d autres d autres textes concernant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire que nous
souhaitions la concorde pour avoir la
concorde il faut donner un geste fort et
ce geste fort pourrait être très
clairement d'écouter les oppositions et
une partie de votre majorité qu'il est
important de la majorité qui est le
mouvement démocrate en disant que le 30
septembre est un geste qui montre que
vous avez entendu aujourd'hui la volonté
des français d'avoir un objectif
réaliste
mes proches le plus proche possible je
remercie
amendements identiques le centre en 14
juillet à la parole bien puisque nous
sommes dans une position commune il sera
également question de date
et c'est la cohérence de la mienne et de
celle de caraman lieu monsieur la tombe
que je veux ici défendre c'est un délai
de trois mois 3mois ouvrait dans
lesquelles les travaux du parlement
auront cours que je propose et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous proposons à
porter la date au 30 septembre
cette date de trois mois ce délai de
trois mois il ne sort pas de nulle part
c'est un une date que nous avions fixé
avec philippe gosselin dans un rapport
évaluant l'état d'urgence sanitaire ou
dans lequel nous estimions que le
parlement devait pouvoir se prononcer
tous les trois mois sur les mesures
restrictives de liberté ou sur les
différentes habilitation pour lequel
nous autorisons le gouvernement à
prendre un certain nombre d'ordonnancés
et parce que nous vous confions des
pouvoirs qui sont extraordinaires ou
exceptionnelles en temps de crise et a
fortiori entendre crise sanitaire
ce délai de trois mois il serait
compliqué de la façon suivante pour
l'amendement que nous proposons la
session ordinaire de juin
du 1er juin au 30 juin la session
extraordinaire de juillet et la très
probable puisque nous le vivons ainsi
depuis le début du quinquennat session
extraordinaire de septembre et c'est la
raison pour laquelle ces trois mois ou
vrai pour le parlement des temps des
travaux qui nous permettront de revenir
ou d'adapter les mesures en tant que la
situation ne nécessitera nous proposons
de rapporter une date qui permettrait en
plus je le crois d'anticiper un peu sur
la navette parlementaire qui aura cours
merci alors sur les amendements bis
comme un avis de la commission mais sur
un porteur vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président je reste attaché à
la date du 31 octobre qui a été retenue
donc par la commission après avoir été
validée par le conseil d'état le conseil
scientifique
il me semble opportune pour plusieurs
raisons la dernière pour vocation de ce
régime par la loi du 14 novembre avait
elle aussi était décidé pour une durée
de cinq mois la loi du 11 juillet 2020
avait également prévu l'échéance du
premier régime transitoire ou 30 octobre
le fait
de prendre la date du 31 octobre ça fait
nous réunir fin septembre fin septembre
c'est un mois après la période estivale
et on ne pourrait connaître les
conséquences
c'est un mois après la vaccination le
gros des vaccinations on pourrait en
connaître les conséquences prendre fin
septembre ça veut dire se réunir au mois
d'août en pleine période estivale est en
pleine vaccination sans en connaître les
conséquences
je pense qu'il est important pour
prendre une décision qu'on connaisse
plus petits conséquence c'est pour ça
que je suis attachée à cette date du 31
octobre en espérant et ça pourrait nous
donner une chance que ce soit le dernier
texte avis défavorable
six matches ministre et la parole
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je vais vous dire une chose moi j'espère
que ce sera ni le 31 octobre ni le 30
septembre
c'est ce qu'on souhaite tous
on souhaite que le virus déguerpissent
qu'on en finisse avec cette vague que la
vaccination bat son plein que les
français partent en vacances comme les
commerces pourront rouler théâtre conte
les restaurants les bars les
discothèques les festivals qu'on
retrouve le goût de la vie ensemble
qu'on relâche à peu la vigilance tout en
étant attentif peut-être même relâché le
masque au coeur de l'été sous un soleil
de plomb s'il se décide à faire beau on
sait jamais il faut venir en bretagne
au moins ne risque pas d'alerté canicule
monsieur le député tout est possible
avec les bretons mais je les mini savez
j'ai des bretons devant moi et derrière
moi je ferais mieux de retourner à mon
propos bref évidemment évidemment enfin
on partage tous ce souhait qu'on ait
plus besoin de se poser la question de
mesures de restriction de jauge de
passes sanitaire de mesures de freinage
ce serait derrière nous une bonne fois
pour toute et qu'on y revienne plus bien
ça c'est le scénario où les choses se
passent bien
auquel cas on aura pas utilité de ce
texte
mais on l'aura si besoin
parce que l'autre scénario qui est pas
impossible c'est un scénario tel qu'on a
pu le vivre l'été dernier juste
replongez vous dans l'été dernier et
considérer l'impact qu'aurait le vote
d'un amendement qui retiennent la date
du 30 septembre mais pas du 31 octobre
l'été dernier ça va bien en france
métropolitaine pas en guyane et une
alerte en mayenne
les français sont en vacances commencent
à se dire qu'on a peut-être vu le bout
du tunnel est au coeur du mois d'août
dans les bouches du rhône
je commence à voir que ça flashe une
augmentation de l'incidence du virus
chez les jeunes souvenez-vous pour
nombre d'experts nous dit c'est pas
grave c'est des jeunes certains disent
même c'est super les jeunes n'ont qu'à
se contaminer les uns les autres
il n'empêche que ben semaine après
semaine jour après jour l'incident salle
a commencé à augmenter et qu'on a
commencé à avoir un petit impact
sanitaire et qu'on a commencé à avoir de
trois points qui flashé sur le
territoire national et là il a fallu
prendre des mesures je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez vous avez peut-être vous
en souvenir des difficultés j'ai fait
trois déplacement dans les bouches du
rhône dont un déplacement en réanimation
en emmenant les élus et les équipes
médicales qui ont communiqué pour dire
la situation telle que nous la vivons
une situation qui nous inquiète
je crois que ça devait être aux
alentours du 26 août nous demandons la
mise en place de mesures très localisés
dans les bouches du rhône de couvre-feu
pour freiner la diffusion du virus
ça n'a pas suffi
il ya eu ensuite la deuxième vague qui a
commencé au début de l'automne qui nous
a été qui nous a contraints à prendre
des mesures d'ampleur
la donne sera différente cet été puisque
nous aurons vacciner et c'est vrai nous
aurons vacciner beaucoup de français
nous ont fait plus de 500000 vaccination
aujourd'hui un record absolu pour un
lundi
on continue d' amplifier vous connaissez
la mobilisation tout le monde sur le
terrain
on aura donc vacciner la population et
elle aura davantage protéger des risques
de contamination et de cas graves
ça c'est ce qui est susceptible de nous
éviter
en tout cas nous l'espérons d'avoir un
repas un nouveau départ épidémique
à la fin de l'été au tout début de
l'automne tel que nous l'avions connu
l'été dernier mais ça ne nous évite pas
ça ne nous évitera pas et c'est ce que
dit le conseil scientifique très clair
sur la question
le risque ça veut pas dire ça va arriver
il ya un risque qui est çà et là des
départs épidémique qui puisse mettre en
péril toute la stratégie sanitaire et
qui nécessitent en urgence d'intervenir
avec quelques mesures de freinage
proportionnelle pour éviter une
extension à tout le pays et nous éviter
de recourir le risque d'une vague
épidémique
je vous parle des bouches du rhône parce
que c'était ça a commencé à la mi août
et que les mesures se sont mises
progressivement en place en septembre
est ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
si nous demandons le 31 octobre c'est
pas parce qu'on envisage que jusqu'au 31
octobre aura des mesures
c'est pour nous éviter de devoir faire
le choix un 1er septembre prochain face
à des foyers épidémiques de devoir
refaire un projet de loi état d'urgence
peut-être pour quelques jours pour
quelques semaines seulement avec des
mesures qui pour le coup serait
peut-être beaucoup plus forte dans la
loi au cas où que les mesures dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui si on prolonge
d'un mois le régime de sortie
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment ça c'est
où nous avons les mesures light pour
pouvoir faire face donc si retire toute
situation y compris au mois de septembre
ou alors nous nous exposons à la
nécessité de convoquer le parlement en
septembre j'ai bien compris que ce
n'était pas un sujet mais avec un projet
de loi haddock et sachant qu'on ne
saurait pas jusqu'où ça irait et
forcément on serait amené présente et
peut-être même un état d'urgence à
proprement parler qui ne serait
peut-être pas au final indispensable et
dont on ne pourrait pas le savoir par
anticipation
donc ce mois en fait de deckard là parce
que je ne reviens pas pardon sur les
amendements qui proposent de tout
arrêter la mi juillet
mais ce mousseux mois d'écart c'est un
mois qui est exact à moi c'est un filet
de sécurité et ce mois d'écart il a
aussi un autre impact qui est important
et pour lequel j'attire votre attention
ce mois d'écart c'est aussi de la
visibilité conférer aux acteurs
économiques à la reprise à la rentrée à
la sortie de l'été pour leur garantir
que si la situation l'exigé ils auront
les mesures d'accompagnement économique
ils auront chômage partiel pour leurs
salariés ils auront le fonds de
solidarité pour les commerçants non vous
avez des commerçants qui vont reprendre
leur activité début septembre qui vont
reprendre leur activité début septembre
avec trois semaines de perspectives si
la situation n'est pas complètement
stabilisé sacré d'anxiété dans le milieu
économique
sacré l'anxiété donc c'était c'est un
bon pour la confiance et quand c'est pas
bon pour la confiance n'est pas bon pour
la croissance
non vraiment ce mois c'est un backup
c'est un filet de sécurité spa pour
priver parlement moi je veux bien même
prendre en vue devant vous l'engagement
que si la situation sanitaire devait
l'exiger etc si on constatait que hélas
malgré tous les efforts et bien un
événement nouveau faisait qu'il y avait
un départ épidémique qui justifiait
qu'on prenne des mesures
au delà du mois d'octobre je viens
m'engager venir vers vous en septembre
et ne pas attendre octobre pour
présenter un projet ça je peux en
prendre un engagement j'ai aucune
difficulté nous l'avons fait c'est le
huitième projet de loi que nous
présentons j'ai aucun problème pour le
faire mais ne nous enlever pas la
possibilité de prolonger de quelques
jours ou de quelques semaines des
mesures même très localisé très
transitoires pour éviter une nouvelle
flambée épidémique dans notre pays à la
rentrée merci
merci et ses mimiques et plusieurs
demandes de prise de parole monsieur la
tombe
monsieur brindeau monsieur de flins g
dupont aignan oui merci monsieur le
président je
excusez moi de le dire comme ça on va
redire ce qu'on s'est dit en commission
vous aviez les mêmes arguments et on
vous a dit qu'on n'avait pas compris ni
monsieur le rapporteur ni monsieur le
ministre votre position refaisons le fil
vous nous dites que vous aviez les
informations dès la mi-août sur la
reprise de l'épidémie en du côté du sud
de la france que vous aviez la crainte
vous avez des projections pour la suite
on a eu des chiffres la face à fin
septembre qui étaient des chiffres on
savait déjà que la reprise épidémique
était partout sur le territoire
même avant et aujourd'hui vous nous
dites bah oui mais ça nous permettrait
aussi économiquement d'avoir des mesures
d'accompagnement social et économique
mais des corps et l'ont les choses le
parlement dans ces perdants ses
prérogatives peut tout à fait revenir
est décidé et nous avons fait preuve
depuis un an un peu plus d'un an et demi
la preuve de notre présence à chaque
fois sur tous les sujets et sans
difficulté présenter un nouveau projet
de loi à l'automne lors d'une session
extraordinaire que nous aurons ne pose
aucun problème
et aujourd'hui donner une perspective
aux français c'est aussi de leur dire
que la vaccination est tous les efforts
qu'ils ont fait depuis un an et demi
leur permet d'avoir une sortie du tunnel
le plus vite possible en responsabilité
on vous dit pas assez le 30 août
parce qu'on peut comprendre qu' il peut
y avoir un effet sur lequel il faut
mesurer mais la plupart des français
vous reprendre le travail au 20 août
les parlementaires peuvent revenir début
septembre
si jamais il y avait besoin sans aucun
problème et je le redis encore une fois
les oppositions vous en faites vous ont
dit plusieurs fois tout qu'il voulait
modifier la date et vous avez demandé à
chaque fois la concorde nationale sur ce
sujet d'état d'urgence la concorde c'est
aussi à un moment de faire un pas pas
simplement d'être bloqué sur ce que vous
avez décidé depuis début mai écouter les
parlementaires dans leurs prérogatives
nous vous demandons vraiment en tant que
pied de la majorité de pouvoir écouter
ce que nous proposons c'est à dire le 30
septembre 2021
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui monsieur le ministre je comprends
pas votre argumentation venu dit
finalement si on prolonge pas par
sécurité au 31 octobre
on prend le risque d'une reprisé copie
des milk qu'on ne contrôleraient pas
suffisamment vite et donc il faut
absolument que le gouvernement dispose
de la totalité des options à mettre sur
la table en matière de freinage de
restrictions et c'est parce que sinon on
prend un risque mais que je sache c'est
exactement ce que vous aviez comme
possibilités comme pouvoir l'année
dernière au moment de la deuxième
reprise et épidémiques et pour autant on
l'a eue la deuxième vague et on a fini
par rétablir l'état d'urgence pour que
leur confinement même allégé par rapport
à ce qu'on a vécu en mars dernier soit
remis en place
donc en fait on était exactement dans la
même situation que ce que vous nous
demandez de vous accorder aujourd'hui et
ça n'a pas empêché sais pas c'est pas le
parlement et les parlementaires qui
débattent à l'assemblée nationale qui
sont la cause d'une reprise épidémique
non c'est simplement la situation de
fait que le relâchement inhérents à
l'été que la présence ensuite de deux
virus variant etc ont fait que bien des
mesures n'ont pas été aussi efficace
qu'on aurait pu effectivement que les
collectivement l'espérer et sur le volet
économique et social pardon de vous dire
que
il faut adapter la loi de finance
également et que donc le parlement sera
amené forcément aussi à re délibérée de
ces questions là donc le sujet n'est pas
là le sujet c'est ce que dit notre
collègue la tombe
il faut que vous ayez un peu de
souplesse et d'ouverture d'esprit pour
que la concorde nationale puisse
éventuellement secret mais moi aussi je
reprendrai monsieur le président les
propos de notre collègue la tombe que je
trouve des propos des propos que je
trouve courageux et maintenant d'un
membre bien connu actifs qui travaillent
de la majorité qui n'est pas suspect de
servir la soupe aux oppositions qui est
droit dans ses bottes et c'est tout à
son honneur quand vous avez un pilier
important de la majorité quand vous avez
des membres comme sacha oublié et
d'autres qui posent des questions qui
sont identiques à celles de l'opposition
il ya un moment faut quand même se poser
quelques questions
on n'a pas raison tout seul on n'a pas
raison tout seul monsieur le ministre
donner des gages à la concorde nationale
c'est aussi accepter la contradiction
parfois c'est aussi accepter de faire
quelques pas personne ne vous demande
ici sauf avec les amendements que nous
avions tout à l'heure de suppression
pour essayer d'alerté mais on n'arrive
pas à vous alerter donc on essaie
d'employer des moyens importants mais
sauf à vouloir être complètement idiot
ou ne pas être un parti de gouvernement
ou je ne sais quoi qui peut prétendre
qu'il a qu'il va empêcher le
gouvernement de travailler personne mais
fait confiance à ce parlement donnait
aussi de la visibilité à nos concitoyens
personne n'est personne n'est dans
l'opposition pour dire si ce texte
s'arrête il n'y aura plus dead etc
non vous le savez très bien donc donné à
la fois de la visibilité aux entreprises
au tourisme
on est d'accord à nos concitoyens mais
donnait aussi de la visibilité au
parlement pour qu'il fasse son travail
monsieur dupont aignan à la parole oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien écouté votre
argumentation
et si j'ai bien compris cela voudrait
dire
que pour qui et de la prévisibilité pour
les acteurs économiques pour qu'on
empêche éventuellement une récidive de
l'épidémie il faut éternellement
suspendre les droits du parlement donc
c'est sans fin parce que vous pourrez
nous dire dans deux mois ou dans trois
mois et même en septembre à il y à un
risque et il faut qu'on prenne des
mesures pour tel ou tel département
c'est absolument sans fin ça ne
s'arrêtera jamais c'est toujours le même
discours
alors il ya un moment même votre
majorité commencent à douter serait bien
la preuve que vous utilisez cette crise
sanitaire pour finalement faire
disparaître le parlement dans son rôle
de contre-pouvoir
c'est la réalité c'est la réalité et ça
fait depuis maintenant mars 2020 ça va
faire un an et demi il n'y a pas une
démocratie où ça se comportent comme
cela
alors c'est pas une caricature c'est la
réalité c'est que vous suspendez les
droits du parlement
vous vous en accommoder et la majorité
des orateurs
monsieur la parole mais en tout cas il
ya une chose de sûre c'est que quand de
l'un d'eux côté de l'hémicycle
en face de moi ici nous étions quelques
collègues et a invoqué tout à l'heure la
question de l' équilibre de pouvoir des
pouvoirs comme problématique vis-à-vis
de cette prolongation s'était pas trompé
je crois qu'il faut monsieur le ministre
arrêter de considérer dans une
démocratie
le parlement est facultatif le parlement
c'est pas une gêne ça peut même vous
permettre d'être plus intelligent et de
prendre des décisions meilleur au fil
des débats que nous avons entre nous je
ne peux pas comprendre l'argument qui
serait de qui est de dire que le 30
septembre
vous ne pourriez pas prendre des mesures
d'urgence nécessaires d'autant plus que
vous le dites vous même ce serait des
mesures vous auriez anticipé quelques
semaines avant parce que le parlement se
réunit sur une é ré enfin est ce que
vous vous rendez compte que quand vous
développer ce genre d'argument vous
envoyer un message terrible aux français
l'idée que pour dire quelque chose
vis-à-vis de la politique du
gouvernement les urnes ne servent à rien
le suffrage universel ne sert à rien
qu'il ne sert à rien d'élire des députés
c'est ça le message que vous envoyez
donc
donc moi ce que nous on vous demande est
manifestement on est beaucoup de
collègues parmi des bancs très divers à
le faire c'est d'accepter cet amendement
qui est à mon avis le minimum et qui
très franchement je ne vois pas je n'ai
pas très bien compris encore dans votre
langue explique à 30 à l'heure
l'argument qui rendrait nécessaire de
s'y opposer pour le gouvernement
monsieur ben cheikh à la parole
la france est quand même d une des rares
démocraties avoir transféré autant de
pouvoirs au pouvoir exécutif pour la
gestion de la crise sanitaire il faut
quand même avoir l'objectivité de
pouvoir enfin de le constater de le
constater nous ne remettons évidemment
pas en cause les décisions prises par le
pouvoir exécutif il ya un moment il faut
prendre des décisions ce que nous
remettons en cause c'est le fait de ne
pas systématiquement en parler devant le
parlement déjà que nous sommes pouvoir
qui n'est vraiment pas décentralisé
notamment sur le plan sanitaire
on voit bien comment on passe notre
temps en permanence s'asseoir sur la vie
des collectivités territoriales je pense
qu'il n'est pas il n'est pas absurde de
vouloir faire en sorte de revenir très
rapidement devant le parlement pour
rediscuter de ces questions et je
voudrais vraiment remercier le modem de
poser ce débat comme vous le posez
actuellement plus on développera la
concertation avec le parlement
meilleures seront les décisions qui
seront prises et je vois pas pourquoi on
hésiterait à à réduire évidemment cette
ce comment ce type fallait l'exécution
l'a27 de cette loi et ce calendrier est
donc je voudrais vraiment appeler
l'attention de nos collègues sur la
nécessité vraiment de pouvoir en
permanence renforcer le rôle du
parlement et faire en sorte que l'on
joue réellement ce rôle à travers un
calendrier vraiment très court puisque
cette loi n'est finalement qu'une
prolongation de la loi d'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais
merci messieurs gauthier chat la parole
merci monsieur le président à faire
venir un instant quand même sur le sujet
de ses amendements et donc le débat
autour autour de la date 31 octobre 30
septembre
notre collègue gilles gosselin l'a
rappelé il ya un instant chaque fois
qu'il ya une date effectivement il y à
ce sujet à débat et il y a sujet à débat
sur sur ces dates
je pense que la date du 31 octobre est
la bonne date et que nous ferions une
erreur en l'art déplaçant au 30
septembre et qu'il faut regarder écouter
ce qu'a dit le ministre
olivier ferrand tout à l'heure sur le
pourquoi du comment cette date du 31
septembre a été choisie est définie elle
a été choisie est définie au regard du
retour d'expérience qu'on peut faire de
l'été dernier et notamment du fait que
s'il fallait refaire un texte
effectivement à l'automne il serait bon
ton que d'avoir en donner l'évaluation
de ce qu'il se passerait à la rentrée
est par ailleurs l'importance de donner
également de la lisibilité aux
françaises et aux français ainsi qu'à
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activité
économique et puis enfin prendre en
compte bien entendu le dernier point les
lallaing la montée en puissance de la
campagne de la campagne vaccinale aussi
cette date du 31 octobre nous paraît
être une date pertinentes et
proportionnée par ailleurs à entendre
certains vous souhaiteriez absolument
avoir un texte à l'automne par mois
j'espère que ce texte est le dernier
texte que nous aurons à faire au regard
de la situation je suis convaincu que ce
sera le dernier texte en tout cas nous
allons tout faire pour y arriver enfin
sur l'aspect démocratique
monsieur dupont-aignan et monsieur
concret et d'autres monsieur porchaire
c'est la huitième fois que nous
débattons dans cet hémicycle de ce sujet
alors oui près il ya une majorité il ya
des oppositions des expressions mais
nous sommes bien dans un état
démocratique et se débat encore lui
aujourd'hui il continuera à avoir lieu
tant que cette crise bien entendu
existera toujours merci merci
madame karamanli moi je voulais juste
monsieur le président je vous remercie
de me donner la parole attirer
l'attention de notre ministre je crois
qu'ici de manière très posait de manière
très résonnait nous avons affaire à des
parlementaires qui travaille depuis
longtemps sur ces sujets nous avons fait
des propositions raisonnables et
responsables
je crois que ne pas faire confiance pour
une fois au parlement
je trouve que ça nous amène encore à
créer encore plus d'insécurité encore
plus finalement de défiance vis-à-vis du
parlement aujourd'hui qui tout le monde
connaît les citoyens le disent aussi vit
des moments difficiles ici notre
collègue la tombe
comme d'autres qui ont fait des rapports
des missions menées au sein des travaux
de la commission des lois ont exprimé
manière poser ses questions
moi je trouve effectivement que ce
serait un pas en avant de donner
d'accepter que le parlement puisse se
prononcer de manière positive sur cet
amendement qui amène la date de fin
septembre qu'il nous donne suffisamment
les garanties pour pouvoir travailler et
qu effectivement à la rentrée nous
pourrons examiner la suite parce que je
suis pas aussi on n'est pas ici d'alpha
mais en tout cas la situation va être
encore difficile et je suis pas certaine
qu'on sera pas amené encore à discuter
sur un projet donc c'est important que
le parlement se saisisse dans les trois
mois qui vont venir
merci monsieur le président belge puis
de président de le monsieur green en
baisse et tous les groupes qui le
souhaitaient ont ainsi pu s'exprimer
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
alors moi je veux bien qu'on fasse de la
politique c'est un peu le lieu pour en
faire et qu' ils soient de tradition que
les oppositions tape sur le gouvernement
mais franchement il ya des choses qu'on
ne peut pas laisser dire laisser dire
que le parlement
n'est pas associé ne décide pas les
mesures sur la crise sanitaire c'est
juridiquement est factuellement faux
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure nous en sommes
huitièmes texte 8e texte depuis 14 mois
ça veut dire que depuis un an et deux
mois nous avons un texte en moyenne tous
les 1,7 mois qui viennent décidé dans
cet hémicycle des mesures qui sont
prises plus plus les commission denquête
l'émission d'information qui ont été
mises en place les questions au
gouvernement
il n'y a aucune mesure aucune mesure
restrictive de liberté qui n'ait été
prise sans qu'elle n'ait été votée
autorisé dans cet hémicycle
c'est ça la réalité juridique et
politique de notre pays
la question qui se pose ce soir est de
savoir et de savoir jusqu'où nous
mettons la date sur la sortie de l'état
d'urgence eh bien nous faisons la
proposition du 31 octobre cette
proposition elle me semble
particulièrement raisonnable dans la
mesure où si nous devions être
confrontés à une nouvelle vague de
l'épidémie
nous savons bien que les mesures qui
sont aujourd'hui dans la loi ne serait
pas suffisante pour faire face et donc
il faudrait nécessairement revenir ici
devant le parlement pour adopter de
nouvelles mesures restrictives de
liberté
je vous encourage ainsi mes chers
collègues à rejeter ces amendements
merci et leur meilleur volley donc nous
allons voter sur les différents
amendements de cette discussion commune
alors elle minutes d'attention il est
premier vote ce roi hamad
et nous terminerons par le vote qui a
suscité le plus de débats qui sera un
vote électronique
alors je comme alors tout tout tout ces
amendements évidemment ont fait l'objet
d'avis défavorable de la commission et
du gouvernement
je commence par la série commençant par
le 50
je commence par le 59 qui est pour
contre rejeté le 213 qui est pour contre
rejeté maintenant une série
d'amendements identiques commençant par
le premier défendu de 60 qui est pour
contre rejeté le centquatre le 104 est
identique qui est pour contre rejeté le
65 qui est pour contre rejeté
et là maintenant nous allons voter su
par voie électronique sur l'amendement
45 est identique
là aussi différents pays sur
gouvernement au scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votre temps ci
explose 106 majorité 54 pour 34 contre
72 d'amendement est donc rejetée le 46e
karamanli vous avez la parole et
monsieur le président yves vermette par
cet amendement 46 et nous souhaitons
nous demandons à ce que
à soumettre finalement les décrets du
premier ministre qui prescrivent des
mesures dans le cadre de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire allégée à l'avis
préalable du conseil d'état
nous l'avons rappelé tout à l'heure lors
des différentes prises de parole qu'en
l'absence d'intervention donc du
parlement comme ça a été décidé
tout au long de la période de validité
de ce régime juridique dérogatoire et
faute d'une définition précise de la
notion de circulation active du virus
qu'on a réclamé des la commission et on
continue de le demander il nous apparaît
donc nécessaire que le conseil d'état
puisse intervenir dans l'appréciation de
la proportionnalité justement des
mesures prises aux circonstances
sanitaire avis de la commission sur un
docteur donc ce le décret du 29 octobre
2022 qui fonde l'ensemble des mesures
prises par le gouvernement pour faire
face à l'épidémie de couver de 19 a été
modifié quarante cinq fois en six mois
la réactivité réglementaire qui exige
l'évolution constante de la situation
sanitaire ne permet pas d'émettre un
avis favorable à votre amendement le
conseil d'état continuent néanmoins de
jouer un rôle essentiel comme conseils
au gouvernement notamment sur les
projets de loi relatifs à la crise
sanitaire et aussi comme juge de décret
qui sont pris en application des
dispositions législatives que nous
adoptons donc c'est un avis défavorable
défavorable également je vais te vois
qui est pour contre rejeté même pujol à
la parole pour le 512 descendîmes
supposés favorables commission défaveur
gouvernement mais je vois qu'ils aient
pour contre je t'ai discussion commune
le 110 le yougoslave puis ça concerne la
limitation de la circulation de nos
concitoyens on est toujours dans la même
continuité réglementée oui mais
interdire me semble aller bien au delà
du raisonnable dans une période où il
n'y a plus d'état d'urgence sanitaire et
finalement si on peut interdire
maintenant comme hier et comme demain il
n'y a pas de fin de ces mesures
restrictives et on reste dans un état
exorbitant du droit commun voilà l'objet
de cet amendement merci d'un discussion
commune mais cela tombe le 125
merci merci la surprise effectivement
cessé le sait le les deux mots ou
interdire qui pose qui pose problème
parce que de fait dé facto ça veut dire
qu'on a un confinement
or vous voulez que les vous avez demandé
des mesures de freinage la possibilité
d'utiliser des mesures de freinage
mesure de freinage ne veut pas dire
forcément des mesures d'interdiction et
les français aujourd'hui on est en train
de leur dire qu'on sort de l'état
d'urgence qu'on va on va essayer de les
emmener progressivement vers la
possibilité d'avoir une vie normale et
on se réserve la possibilité de pouvoir
interdire toute circulation de personnes
et où deux véhicules
c'est pas cohérent donc aujourd'hui vous
n'ayez des mesures de freinage oui que
vous avez des mesures d'interdiction
stricte non merci
sur ces amendements de la commission
merci monsieur le président je veux être
extrêmement clair avec nos collègues en
particulier du groupe modène ces
dispositions relatives à l'interdiction
de la circulation n'a pas vocation à
permettre de rétablir ni le confinement
ni le couvre-feu nous aurons d'ailleurs
ce débat juridique un peu plus tard
l'intention du législateur avait
clairement été exprimé lors de la
discussion de la loi du 9 juillet 2020
tu es cela avait été d'ailleurs relevé
par le conseil constitutionnel
votre amendement me donne cependant
l'opportunité qu'elle le soit à nouveau
pour ce nouveau régime transitoire le
dispositif de ce que ces amendements
souhaite supprimer ne constitue ni une
nouvelle disposition par rapport au
précédent régime transitoire ni une
mesure plus restrictive que ce qui est
prévu par l'état d'urgence sanitaire
bien au contraire la proportionnalité de
cette année alinéa été validée par le
conseil constitutionnel l'année dernière
vous conviendrez enfin que ce n'est pas
parce que cette disposition était active
a dès l'été 2020 en cas de forte
dégradation de localiser de la situation
sanitaire que les français sont pourtant
restés enfermés chez eux tout le mois
d'août je pense que c'est même l'inversé
qui s'est produit
avis défavorable merci monsieur ministre
défavorable monsieur dupont-aignan à la
parole monsieur le président monsieur
mini ces amendements sont de bon sens
parce que tout à l'heure
certains nombres de la majorité nous
expliquer que finalement c'est la
huitième fois que c'est pas si grave et
justement c'est grave parce que c'est la
huitième fois et que ça dure depuis mars
2020 et donc à force de signer des
chèques en blanc en permanence
eh bien vous perdez l'habitude d'exercer
vos responsabilités de parlementaire et
on ne peut pas dire que ce n'est pas
grave puisque justement il y à ce terme
d'interdiction de déplacement
cette termes d'interdiction que veut
lever ces amendements donc il me paraît
quand même assez surréaliste une
nouvelle fois qu'une assemblée nationale
dans un pays démocratique comme le nôtre
accepte pour la 8e fois de donner les
pleins pouvoirs un chèque en blanc à un
gouvernement qui de surcroît et je
n'aborde même pas ce point a échoué sur
beaucoup de choses
depuis qu'on lui a confié ses pleins
pouvoirs alors non seulement on
abandonne au pouvoir pour la huitième
fois et en plus on ne peut pas dire que
les résultats fut à la hauteur de
l'espérance pour les députés de la
majorité c'est encore pire parce que ce
sont eux en fait qu'ils se privent le
plus du contrôle qu'il devrait exercer
sur leur gouvernement en tout cas c'est
un moment profondément grave pour notre
parlement je le répète et c'est pourquoi
au moins cet amendement permettrait
d'éviter les interdictions fatale mais
secret mais moi je comprends pas comment
le gouvernement ne peut pas accepter cet
amendement parce que talent je vous ai
entendu monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez présenté très aimable cette loi
comme celle j'ai à l'égard de transition
d'une sortie progressive de la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes si c'est la
loi que vous dites
dans ces cas là je ne vois pas pourquoi
on aurait besoin de prendre des mesures
qui étaient celles que vous estimiez
nécessaires y ait un an ou alors c'est
que c'est pas une loi de sortie de la
crise que nous subissons c'est en
réalité une prolongation
une adaptation que vous continuez à nous
proposer donc dans votre logique si vos
paroles sont vraies je ne vois pas
pourquoi réglementés ne suffiraient pas
et pourquoi il vous faudrait arriver
justement à des mesures de coercition
comme celle d'interdire ou alors c'est
que ce que vous nous dites est faux et
que en réalité nous sommes juste dans un
moment transitoire entre un état
d'urgence un état d'exception et un
futur état d'urgence merci merci j'ai
mes dents qu'on voit ces amendements
identiques 110 et 125 font l'objet d'un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour l'heure à
l'option qui est contre je t'ai donné
pas défendu le 4 pas davantage
je 123 et défendu défavorable commission
défavorable gouvernement genevois qui
est pour contre rejeté le 85
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président donc c'est un amendement
proposé par notre collègue philippe
dunoyer qui en plus dans le cadre du
pass sanitaires prévoient la possibilité
d'un test sérologique permettant la
détection dandy d'anticorps et ça
m'amène à reposer la question que j'ai
déjà posé donc à deux reprises désormais
sur lesquels j'aimerais beaucoup avoir
un élément de réponse du ministre qui
est qu'effectivement aujourd'hui il est
prévu qu'un certificat en fait un
testant de la contamination de la
personne et donc du développement chez
elle d'anticorps liés naturellement et
non pas au vaccin mais lier
naturellement la lutte contre la maladie
pourrait être intégré à l'arsenal
j'allais dire d'options dans le cadre de
ce passeport de ce pass vaccination de
ce pass sanitaire pardon est ce que vous
pourriez nous éclairer encore une fois
sur l'état d'avancement des des
recherches des autorités sanitaires
européennes et nationales
j'ai pas de chance parce qu'à chaque
fois que je pose la question le ministre
sort de la sorte de l'hémicycle donc je
vais être obligé de le reposer encore
une quatrième fois tout alors j'imagine
merci aux avis de la commission c'est
une demande de retrait s'est satisfait
et bien prévu de permettre de présenter
un document attestant du rétablissement
à la suite d'une contamination par le
comique 19
s'agissant du problème que vous soulevez
la haute autorité de santé recommande
aux personnes pour lesquelles le
prélèvement nasopharyngé est difficile
ou impossible pour des raisons médicales
ou du fait que la situation personnelle
de demander aux professionnels de santé
d'adapter le test pcr par prélèvements
auront faim
et où salivaire donc avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre monsieur le député
en fait votre abandon est satisfaits
dans la mesure où aujourd'hui
le texte prévoit la possibilité de
présenter un document certifiant du
rétablissement de la personne concernée
qui laisse donc la possibilité soit
d'utiliser un test positif et c'est j'y
reviendrai ce qui à ce stade a été
retenu notamment au niveau européen et
ce que nous retenons au niveau français
soit le cas échéant si cela devait être
confirmée par les autorités sanitaires
un test sérologique à ce jour le conseil
scientifique a rendu un avis extrêmement
clair sur le sujet ils ne recommandent
pas que nous puissions utiliser les
tests sérologiques pour valider du
rétablissement d'une personne et c'est
également ce que semble indiquer en tout
cas la direction qui est en train de
prendre la discussion européenne ceci
pourrait évidemment changer en fonction
de l'avis des autorités scientifiques
mais à ce jour nous partirons sur un
test positif
deux semaines après un test positif on
estime qu'à ce moment là cela suffit à
confirmer l'immunité de quelqu'un il y à
un débat scientifique à ce jour est ce
que c'est de deux semaines à deux mois
ou deux semaines à six mois nous sommes
en train de creuser ce point là avec le
conseil scientifique mais pour le moment
les autorités scientifiques ne nous
demande de ne pas utiliser les tests
sérologiques si ceux ci devaient être
validées
à l'avenir la formulation telle qu'elle
est prévue nous permettra de recourir
vain d'ajouter les tests sérologiques en
tout cas l'objectif que nous poursuivons
c'est de ne pas fermer la porte aux
tests sérologiques mes données utilisées
que dès lors que les autorités
scientifiques françaises européennes
également nous les valideront donc votre
amendement est satisfait c'est pourquoi
nous vous demanderons de le
retirée faute de quoi nous serons
défavorable merci
même madame venayre je suis bon tenir je
suis brindeau merci monsieur le
président je suis assez surprise de
cette réponse parce que tous documents
qui permettraient de justifier un
rétablissement
on n'entend qu'un simple certificat
médical est peut-être monsieur le
ministre que vous êtes en train de nous
dire qu'on va pouvoir faire confiance
aux médecins et qui dira établissements
dits état de santé retour un examen
clinique tout à fait normal donc à
simple certificat médical quelconque
d'un médecin généraliste pouvant nous
certifier que la personne est rétabli
serait suffisante pour satisfaire à ses
obligations en tout cas c'est le sens de
votre réponse et aujourd'hui nous
pouvons nous en satisfaire parce que
depuis tout à l'heure
et pour en revenir aux questions de
délais il aurait été tout à fait
satisfaisant en effet que cet état
d'urgence puissent prendre fin
réellement au 31 septembre
si vous même vous faisiez confiance dans
votre stratégie vaccinale
or on se rend bien compte que non
seulement aujourd'hui on vaccine les
personnes à la veulent là aussi sans
vérifier leur statut sérologique
ce qui est quand même une première dans
le monde qu'on continue à vacciner
pendant une épidémie ce qui là aussi
continue à être tout à fait surprenant
mais que vous laisser sous-entendre
français que vous ne faites pas
confiance dans votre propre stratégie
puisque sinon vous pourriez proposait en
effet que le délai soit le 30 septembre
je vous remercie merci monsieur lui pris
la parole oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre si j'ai bien
compris la réponse du ministre en fait
le gouvernement n'a pas vraiment choisi
est toujours dépendant de négociation
européenne
donc en fait dans cette affaire on voit
que depuis le début le gouvernement est
à la remorque mot remorque de l'union
européenne que ces positions changent au
gré des négociations mais moi j'aimerais
que le gouvernement nous donne on nous
donne exactement la position de la
france
et quelle position le gouvernement
défend à bruxelles plutôt que de nous
dire on va voir selon les négociations
je pense qu'un pays comme la france
pourrait déjà savoir ce qu'il veut
monsieur brun de oh oui merci j'avoue
monsieur dominique du mal à vous suivre
dans votre dans votre explication parce
que si j'ai bien compris ce que vous me
dites vous dites un test positif qui par
voie de conséquence va tester du
rétablissement et donc de la présence
d'anticorps contre lakovic 19 va être
possible dans le cadre du pass
sanitaires etc en revanche le test
sérologique
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas et on attend
quelque part des confirmations sur le
débat scientifique qui consiste à savoir
si quelque part ces anticorps que vous
développez suite à l'avoir contracté la
maladie vous protège plus de deux mois
ou jusqu'à six mois et que donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle les tests
sérologiques ne serait pas intégré pour
l'instant à ceux à ce paquet je jouais
juste attirer votre attention sur une
chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui les personnes
qui font des tests sérologiques qui se
révèle positif c'est-à-dire la présence
d'anticorps sur sur la lutte contre la
copie 19 ces tests là ne font plus la
distinction entre le fait que ces
anticorps proviennent de la vaccination
ou pas ah bah si c'est vrai chers
collègues parce que je peux je peux
attester
mais chers collègues à yahoo je vous
emmènerai le certificat de la personne
qui a obtenu cela suit effectivement au
fait qu'elle ait contracté la maladie
mais pas qu'elles aient été vaccinées et
le test dit où il dit bien
contraction de la maladie ou vaccination
donc on a un problème sur le sujet je
suis désolé vieille oh oui merci
monsieur présent juste une précision je
passerai tout à l'heure la un évidement
sur la volonté de l'anonymat de mon
collègue brindeau mai
le résultat de mes tests sérologiques
sérologique par le post vaccinaux et on
voit bien qu'en fonction du test on sait
parfaitement s'il ya des anticorps
contre le virus sauvage et des anticorps
et sait pas où c'est alternatifs ou des
anticorps qui sont contre la protéine
vaccinale et on le voit bien et c'est un
drame c'est un outil extrêmement
intéressant extrêmement performant
extrêmement utiles pour suivre
l'efficacité de la vaccination
je vous passerais tout à l'heure la
photo vous et merci
je mets donc on voit le 85 des voix
commission gouvernementale pour contre
je t'ai discussion commune monsieur pull
195 vous avez la parole oui merci nous
ne sommes pas contre le pass sanitaires
notamment pour les entrées et sorties du
territoire national simplement à travers
ces amendements
nous pensons qu'il n'est pas raisonnable
à cette heure d'inclure la notion du
vaccin puisque aujourd'hui le notre pays
a une couverture vaccinale assez faible
et nous avons pas une visibilité
totalement éclairer sur les échéances
qui nous permettront d'atteindre une
couverture vaccinale importante donc à
ce stade il nous semble
nécessaire de retirer cela de critères
du pas saint maxin à sa détermination
merci là dans la discussion commune
monsieur brindeau le creux samedi
oui c'est un amendement un peu dans le
même état d'esprit que l'amendement du
collègue stéphane peu c'est à dire à
partir du moment où on inclut la
vaccination dans ce pass sanitaires
comme étant une possibilité il faut
effectivement que l'ensemble de la
population puisse avoir accès aux
vaccins et là je le dis très clairement
nous voulons que la totalité si c'est
possible mais que la plus grande partie
de nos concitoyens se fassent vacciner
pour rentrer dans les mesures
d'ouverture des restaurants des lieux
accueillant du public etc
ça veut dire que dès maintenant il faut
permettre à tous de pouvoir être vacciné
sans plus aucune condition et d'âge et
de condition de comorbidité ça c'est une
évidence il faut faire évoluer notre
stratégie vaccinale sur le sujet et puis
sans avoir l'air de de créer un débat
avec le collègue et yahoo c'est parce
que j'ai dit
le test permet de faire la différence
bien sûr c'est le certificat qui est
délivrée qui ne fait plus la différence
il ne le fait pas la différence c'est
écrit vaccin ou de manière naturelle
suite à la contraction de la maladie ce
qui pose de problèmes spécifiquement
lorsque on intégrera le sujet ou pas
d'ailleurs dans le cadre du pass
sanitaires merci oui il ya un vrai sujet
merci monsieur le président il ya un
vrai sujet avec ce pass sanitaires on
peut pas évacuer la question d'un revers
de main et évidemment et ce n'est pas le
sujet mais s'inquiéter quand même des
modalités
d'arrivée de ce sujet dans nos dans nos
débats
c'est un amendement du gouvernement qui
est arrivé donc sans l'avis du conseil
d'état
la cnil va être consultés jeudi bien va
être consulté au lendemain du vote qui
de notre texte qui va intervenir ce soir
ou demain puisque la cnil ne rendra un
avis que ce mercredi c'est quand même un
peu fâché d'avoir deux grandes
d'autorité sur un tel sujet qui n'ont
pas pu émettre d'avis en comparaison je
voudrais vous vous éclairer sur ce qu'a
fait l'autorité de contrôle italienne
d'autorité de contrôle italienne a émis
un avis négatif avec conditions à ce
passe sanitaire l'autorité de contrôle
hollandaise l'équivalent de la cnil a
aussi émis un avis très circonstancié ça
montre que le sujet n'est pas aussi
simple qu'on veut bien nous le vendre
premier point il faut le rappeler avec
avec force à ce stade
inclure la vaccination pose de vraies
questions on va nous dire oui mais on
peut très bien faire des tests ça
suffira etc
sauf que si on le fait qu à proximité de
grands rassemblements de foire de salon
on n'est pas sûr que les centres de
tests ne soient pas à saturation
et puis on nous dit attention ne fera
pas l'essentiel
mais qu'est-ce que l'essentiel c'est
aussi une vraie une vraie question pour
les intel chose est essentiel pour tel
autre ça ne l'est pas on nous empêchera
par exemple de visiter certains parcs de
participer à certaines animations parce
qu'elles seront considéré comme non
essentiels et parfois en ayant moins de
monde que des supermarchés qui réuniront
plus de 1000 personnes
donc la logique si vous voulez quand
même assez compliqué et tout le temps
que la vaccination n'est pas généralisé
il nous paraît en plus difficile
impossible d'inclure cette vaccination
dans les demandes et dans les besoins de
certificats méfie
monsieur m'a dit pour le top 10 oui
monsieur le président l'amendement 106
et un amendement de repli par rapport à
l'amendement de mon collègue 105 mon
collègue au cela avec les mêmes elles
mêmes arguments merci merci sur ces
petits qui se commet une mesure à porter
merci monsieur le président c'est vrai
qu'on cherche à ce que le plus de monde
possible soient vaccinés mais de toute
façon il y aura toujours des gens non
vaccinées soit parce que ils n'ont pas
eu le temps
soit qu'ils ne peuvent pas médicalement
ou alors comment dire soit qu'il ne
veulent pas donc on a toujours la
solution d'avoir se paie sierre négatifs
comme preuve plutôt que la vaccination
donc il n'est pas juste de conditionner
l'entrée en vigueur de ce dispositif à
l'accès de toute la population à ce
matin donc ce sera un avis négatif
défavorable même avis défavorable mais
la réponse
j'aurais bien aimé éventuellement avoir
quelques éclairages sur le fait que ça
ne vous gêne pas que la cnil n'est pas
pu rendre d'avis que le conseil d'état
n'est pas pu se prononcer je trouve que
c'est quand même assez fâché on a une
autorité de contrôle chargé des libertés
informatiques depuis 78 qui a des
pouvoirs renforcés depuis 2004 c'est la
cnil et on la passe sous silence le
conseil d'état en étant pleinement plein
bicentenaire napoléonien création de ce
conseil d'état on le passe sous silence
c'est pas grave circulez ya rien à voir
quand au fait monsieur le rapporteur qui
niait qui est évidemment des gens qui ne
soit pas vaccinés y en aura toujours
bien sûr il y en aura toujours mais
aujourd'hui ceux qui veulent être
vaccinés ne le peuvent pas encore je ne
porte pas de jugement à ce stade négatif
sur l'impréparation et c'est pas mon
sujet le fait est que aujourd'hui celles
et ceux qui veulent se faire vacciner ne
le peuvent pas encore et ça va durer un
certain temps
donc ce que l'on veut ce que l'on
souhaite c'est que celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas pu se faire vacciner ne soit
pas obligé de le faire si
les autotests si les tests pcr ne sont
pas en nombre suffisant et on peut très
bien avoir de l'encombrement à l'entrée
de certains festivals des dates de
validité qui ne sont pas bonnes
et encore une fois une question de
cohérence on va permettre et c'est très
bien aux gens d'aller faire des courses
d'aller éventuellement dans des
supermarchés des magasins de bricolage
et c'est d'être plus de 1000 et on va
empêcher d'autres d'aller dans des
concerts dans des parcs zoologiques dans
des centres d'activités etc etc
donc il ya une incohérence qui n'est pas
levée par cet amendement
et c'est cette incohérence que l'on veut
réellement pointé merci monsieur
dupont-aignan
oui de ces amendements sont les
bienvenus monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre en vérité le fond du
problème c'est que ce pass sanitaire est
introduit dans nos débats alors même que
la cnil qui est quand même l'autorité
qui est censé défendre nos libertés n'a
pas été consultée dans cette affaire ni
le conseil d'état c'est un précédent
extrêmement grave
cela veut dire que l'accès à certaines
manifestations sera soumis un traçage un
traçage numérique c'est la réalité et
vous mettez le doigt dans l'engrenage
vous mettez un doigt dans un engrenage
terrible cela veut dire que soit ce sera
une usine à gaz extrêmement compliqué
parce qu'il faudra que vous nous
expliquer quels sont les délais que vous
mettez pour la pertinence de la
vaccination
combien de temps et ont couvert par les
vaccins quels vaccins qu'elle variant
comment allez vous gérer cette affaire
ensuite pour les tests sérologiques pour
ceux qui ont eu la qu'ovide et puis
comment les tests seront assurés et
comment ils seront mis à disposition
donc cela veut dire que quand on voit la
décision de la commission italienne
quand on voit les réserves aux pays-bas
que cette affaire est un grand bricolage
que vous précipiter là dedans mais que
dans les modalités pratiques
la cnil n'a pas délibéré et je pense que
suite été bien utile la parole monsieur
le président pour répondre à monsieur
gosselin monsieur dupont-aignan d'abord
sur monsieur coup ça vous pointer les
incohérences
trouve que dans votre argumentation une
forme d'incohérence vous nous dites bon
il ya des fois on va vouloir aller dans
un festival et on va manquer de test
d'abord je rappelle que ces tests pcr ou
antigénique dans le dispositif du pass
sanitaire donc même si vous n'avez pas
prévu à l'avance de vous faire tester
vous pouvez toujours aller dans une
pharmacie disposer d'un test anti
génique et c'est bien pour ça que ça n'a
aucun sens monsieur gosselin d'exclure
la vaccination
parce que si vous dites en fait on va
manquer test parce que vous voulez aller
voir dans un aller dans un festival est
donc mais dans ce cas-là n'excluait pas
la vaccination ça va justement permettre
de faire en sorte que ceux qui ont été
vaccinés n'auront pas besoin d'un test
pcr demande d'ailleurs de nos
compatriotes ultramarins assez pressante
nombre d'entre eux sont vaccinés pour
venir en aide dans l'hexagone ils ont
besoin d'un test pcr et ils nous disent
mais ça n'a pas de sens j'ai été vacciné
évidemment que le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais ma contagiosité
elle a diminué et donc éviter moi
d'aller me faire un petit plaisir nasale
si je peux me permettre
qui est absolument superfétatoire dans
la mesure où j'ai déjà été vaccinées
deuxième élément pour répondre sur le
conseil d'état à la crise monsieur
dupont-aignan je pense que vous avez un
petit problème de base juridique
si la question c'est de savoir est ce
que on permet à des gens d'entrer sur la
base de tests positifs ou d'une données
sanitaires pardon c'est pas la cnil qui
est concerné je pense que vous avez un
petit problème de compréhension de la
loi c'est le conseil d'état vous avez
raison la cnil n'a rien à voir là dedans
la cnil s'occupe du traitement
informatique et libertés et donc elle
peut se prononcer sur le fait qu'on ait
un lecteur etc il n'y a pas de nouveaux
traitements informatiques dans le fait
de présenter un qr code
puisque le traitement informatique
cecileb c'est si vrai que ça ça continue
sur la question du conseil d'état je
rappelle qu' il y avait eu un débat
politique sur
le projet de loi qui avait été présenté
par le gouvernement en décembre sur
lequel le conseil d'état qui allait plus
loin dans la capacité donnée à l'état a
limité l'accès à des rassemblements le
conseil d'état n'y avait rien trouvé à
redire
donc s'ils n'avaient rien trouvé à
redire au projet de loi de décembre
je ne vois pas pourquoi enfin on peut
considérer qu'il avait donné son avis
sur l'accès le projet de l'essaim de
décembre était bien plus grand donc le
conseil d'état s'est prononcé sur la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés effectivement elle doit se
prononcer non pas sur la condition
d'accès ça c'est le conseil d'état
monsieur dupont-aignan elle doit se
prononcer sur le traitement informatique
qui est fait dans le lecteur qui permet
d'être vert ou rouge qui me semble assez
limité pour permettre au parlement de se
prononcer avant mais il faut pas se
tromper sur la base légale monsieur
dupont-aignan
merci dont je vais me retrouver
successivement ces différents
amendements en commençant par le soeur
qui tous sont logés un avis défavorable
la commission du gouvernement
le 195 qui est pour contre rejeté le 70
ce qui est pur contre je t'ai 205 même
avis même vote
le 106 mais ma vie même butt le 126
monsieur la tombe
oui merci monsieur le président il
s'agit dans cet amendement de faire
référence à la ce que l'union européenne
va mettre dans le règlement dans son
règlement elle nous dit aujourd'hui dans
ce dans le projet de règlement que ça
sera un certificat de rétablissement or
dans le texte vous avez un libellé qui
est différent or nous pensons qu'il ne
faut pas sûr transposer ce que nous dit
l'union européenne qui peut au contraire
rester dans ce que l'union de nous
propose est donc vraiment de rester dans
la définition telle qu'elle est prévue
c'est-à-dire d'un certificat de
rétablissement ce qui permet aussi et
c'est assez c'est assez
assez logique de pouvoir rester dans
l'ensemble des préconisations de l'union
quant aux tests utilisés possible les
délais etc
ça montre bien qu'aujourd'hui la france
prend la réglementation européenne telle
qu'elle est ne la sueur transpose pas et
ne fait pas non plus du plus sûr sûr sûr
sûr cette partie là et que l'ensemble de
l'union va avancer de la même femme
ce qui est très important notamment dans
le cadre des mouvements de personnes qui
va pouvoir va pouvoir avoir lieu cet été
parce que nous comptons sur les
touristes nous comptons sur le fait que
nous pourrons avoir des touristes pour
pouvoir relancer le tourisme en france
et le fait que nous ayons éventuellement
une définition différente de celle que
d'autres pays pourraient avoir parce
qu'ils ont adopté la définition de
l'union poserait un problème clair pour
les touristes qui oserait aujourd'hui en
france
merci messieurs la porter merci monsieur
peillon si la commission n'a pas retenu
cet événement à titre personnel je suis
favorable à cette position qui me
semblent opportunes et d'une nature à
renforcer ce dispositif
messieurs ministre sagesse dont je mets
de voir le farman si ce qui est pour
quand
adoptez grèce qui fait tomber non le 130
2 932 qu'il est défendu vis un vrai si
le seul président c'est un amendement
que j'ai présente avec mon collègue et
isaac sybille et et bertha visant à
préciser la notion de rétablissement
mais alors je sais pas si on a toujours
su si ce mot comme l'avait d'ailleurs
dit dans son avis le conseil d'état
on s'interroge sur cette notion d' oncle
l'amendement vise à apporter cette
précision en s'alignant donc sur la
rédaction de projets de règlements de
certificats verts européens
la production d'un résultat à un test
d'un résultat un test sérologique ne
s'oppose pas non plus au secret médical
la production d'anticorps pouvant être
secondaire à une contamination ou à une
vaccination
merci mr sylla à porter cette notion
doit encore faire l'objet
d'approfondissement scientifiques
nécessaires et d'une ultime
harmonisation au niveau européen en
effet vous le rappeler le conseil d'état
a validé la formulation qui est proposée
par le projet de loi
par contre concernant la proposition que
vous formulez vous faites référence aux
résultats d'un test biologique positif
ce qui aurait pour conséquence de
permettre à une personne malade est
contagieuse de voyager donc demande de
retrait avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre même avis
défavorable il est maintenu je le mets
aux voix je vais donc voir 132 avis
défavorable commissions vers ne manquiez
pour contre il est rejeté prochaine
séance ce soir 21h suite du projet de
loi relatifs à la gestion de la sortie
de crise sanitaire
la séance est levée